Do we have power?
Yes.
Yes,
yes.
The machine.
Ladies and gentlemen
on Showtime.
Bert Kreischer,
Douglas Douglas,
me,
boy.
Doug's dad hope
almost married him in
the early two thousands
if Marilyn Manson wants to come around,
you can come out.
Bill burrs here.
Bill Burton,
Ladies and gentlemen,
because I stutter.
Bill Bird,
just good
calming.
Wait,
where are you?
Silly Diaz.
This calming Judge Judy as he's come in.
You told me I started doing.
A lot of people are coming.
We're watching
Greg Fitzsimmons.
Everybody says,
Ladies and gentlemen,
Gray's gonna start drinking tonight.
Rogan is there.
It's over
Kroger.
Dot.
This is all I have.
All I have is a fake smile
and an opener wrote something.
No,
I,
this is a text I sent to
you last week when I was at,
I thought the worst day
of my life until today.
And I came to town to try to organize
this and I don't know what the fuck,
I can't live stream.
What does it,
you have a car.
So this is what I sent
to Rogan at the depths
of what I thought was
the worst hangover ever.
We're all adults,
folks.
This is bullshit.
Even even worrying about this is both
with cotton candy here.
This is what I wrote
to rogue in a week ago.
I get a date right
there and hit that bill.
I wrote a lot of shit.
A little cool.
I'm in a serious panic mode
and really want to bail on it.
Meaning this,
I think it's a great idea,
but I have no idea how to
organize it and it's so close.
The comedy store gave us the day
and I don't want to fuck them over,
but I don't know how to make this work.
I fucked up and don't know
how to put it together.
I don't want to put all this on you,
but I don't want to be the guy
responsible for an abortion,
but way far only you and a
vague bill burr have committed.
I want to fake a stroke
to get out of ruining.
It saved me.
Ps has been a long week.
Rogan,
very succinctly
rights back.
We'll figure it.
Oh fuck man.
That's it.
I'll handle it.
Don't sweat it.
It's nothing.
We show up.
We drank.
I smoked pot pot.
We talk easy.
[inaudible]
fucking Rogan says it's good.
It's good.
Made it road on the man show.
Get two guys.
Oh really?
Do you still get hate mail from them?
No.
The writers,
no one's no,
but I can say there was a,
there was very little preparation and a,
and there was some funny fucking
monologues that were on that show.
We had some fun.
Yeah,
you don't need preparation then
sometimes you do like right now.
Well,
I had that.
I had that
fill that out.
That weird.
I like the Doug always.
I don't want to be the guy
responsible for an abortion,
but he's totally had abortions
that he's paid for her
for Christ.
You're bringing it down.
Plus when Donald Trump becomes president,
you're a fucking criminal portion.
Draws it at eight for a
plethora of abortions.
By the way,
if you thought this was going
to be about the election,
no,
it's the end of the world.
Either way.
Yeah.
If you guys,
we wouldn't pay here.
I do have to.
I have to do this.
Brent Ericson Ericson.
We do have our breaking news guy,
Brent Ericson.
Fantastic comic is actually
having to watch the CNN coverage.
So anything actually does matter.
He'll run out and be breaking.
He has a laptop.
Yeah,
kind of lyrics and he's watching it.
That's fine.
We can just do four
hours before the shows.
I do you have any TV screens?
Are there any laptops?
What are we going to do out there?
Very hasty.
Hastily thrown together
yet planned for months.
You texted me about this easily in August,
easily
a year ago.
He came up with it.
I realized,
no,
I think everyone doesn't like me.
When you returned my texts,
they were scared that girl.
Aw,
that's adorable.
Yeah.
So,
uh,
yeah,
there's uh,
an election.
It doesn't matter if you care
about does it Kinda does.
What matters the most is
that no matter who wins,
we're both,
we're all of us really alike.
Okay.
I mean,
it's not good.
No.
If Trump wins when Obama won,
didn't you feel like,
wow,
this is some new shit.
A guy couldn't form full sentences,
went to actual schools.
That's very racial,
very articulate
as opposed to George Bush.
You fuck.
That's how I look.
We were happy.
We're having them look at
this really articulate,
intelligent guy that's reasonable.
What he does on election day.
It's your tradition not making this up.
He plays basketball on election day.
Good for him.
I heard that on CNN today.
That's why I talk shows
actually have screeners and go,
hey,
what are you going to say?
At what point?
[inaudible] you have an
interesting story about,
you could be like Byron
Allen on that late night show
going to the zoo.
Completely different.
Bill Furry like to water ski.
Slowly a bit funny.
You brought that up
and here's my anecdote.
That fits perfectly right
before the commercial.
Don't forget to segway to
Kreischer with something completely
different.
Friday night for Chrysler
in the machine on showtime.
Then 11
respect to the machine.
I get a cut of the Nachos,
so get some Nachos.
They're very good.
They squeezed that by hand.
That sauce.
I feel about Nachos at the comedy store
the same way I feel about whoever the
fuck wins.
President.
Alright,
got to do what you gotta do,
man.
Press real younger.
If the president really affects your life,
you've made poor choices or you met him.
What if you met that
Guy Jon Stewart thing?
50 years old.
But you see the Jon Stewart thing,
your muscles don't know it.
Jon Stewart,
uh,
did some veterans show and on the veterans
show he read out this tweet exchange
he had with Donald Trump.
It's like in his ass now.
It's fucking hilarious.
And Donald Trump's tweets
him at one 30 in the morning.
Little Jon Stewart is a pussy and
we'll be hopeless in a debate with me.
And he's a liar because
he changed his name.
That would go,
that's the best joke.
Cause he goes,
his real name's Jon Stewart or his real
name is John [inaudible] and Burger
whatever.
Liebowitz Chin.
And then Jon Stewart wrote back,
John Jay,
that's right.
And Donald Trump's real name is fuck
face bond sticker with by clowns.
Stick mouth.
Fuckface von clowns thinking he doesn't
know why he won't embrace the von
clowns.
Pick camp heritage.
And at the end of it,
one 30 in the morning,
Trump tweets him at one 30 in the morning.
Little Jon Stewart is a pussy
and we'd be hopeless in a debate with me.
I wouldn't even
I,
I'm,
I'm going to,
I'll be the dude.
That means he was walking
around talking to himself.
Yes,
they,
they debriefed him for the next
presidential thing and he goes,
all right,
I will see you later.
And he closed the doors walking around
in his gold toed socks and his fucking
hotel room.
Fucking noodle took off with
saying I'm a fucking asshole.
He had probably some woman.
They're going,
Donald Telco on the Internet
is shit.
I'm not taking this shit from him.
Fucking liberal media.
I fucking tweaking this thing out here.
We probably like it all down below.
What's worse is he was really to do that.
Who is doing that?
Is the system following him around?
Tell no che dish.
No,
don't hit send.
Yeah.
Shay Desk.
Who Buy your pussy?
I'll fuck it on its head.
Don't hit send.
That's Mr. Trump.
That's going to have the red phone.
That's going to have the red phone dude
him and five whatever Vladimir,
whatever that fucking Russian
dude's name is like vitamin.
You wait till one time
when his fucking off,
he'll call him on the red phone.
Well,
I think we're going to find out if
that guy can really do anything.
Like we never really knew if the president
can actually do anything because they
always seem to promise one thing and they
get an officer to a totally different
deal.
Once they're inside,
we're going to find out what this guy,
if he really gets in there,
he's going to start talking shit.
Oh.
Like from inside the White House talking
shit about how the government works so
they won't do his bidding.
It's going to get really fucking weird.
Oh,
you're going to hear that to that,
uh,
that the song by Bachman Turner overdrive,
you ain't seen nothing yet.
She shows you how fragile this
group of people really is.
This weird group of people
that we call America.
We're about to elect a douchebag.
Either wipe verifiable,
but upside Joe is,
we'll probably get to
see an assassination.
Oh,
hey,
no,
we,
I can't believe he went
there Friday all 1111.
She is an update Cotsen Hannah again,
the filthy uncut.
Scott's Wisconsin's now,
boom.
What do we got?
Oh,
I've done that are breaking news guy,
Brent Ericson.
What do you have?
Break
this.
Justin.
Bert Kreischer special Friday night.
Showtime
rejoices wait too fucking high for this.
November 11 and Gary Johnson
is that 3.7% and when
you were supposed to get Gary Johnson
on did come on the podcast,
we lost him to CNN.
Well the second time you
and I were supposed to do a
podcast together with Gary
Johnson who was all in,
but we lost him.
A CNN.
Gary Johnson.
Why?
Cause he follows me on Twitter.
That's reason enough.
There you go.
Yes.
Come on ladies.
You tell me.
Stop.
Take your whip.
My Dick.
Stop voting with your
vagina or vote Jill Stein.
That map looks like somebody hit one
of those avatar people with a truck.
I'm just killing me all the college ways.
How to glue thing.
Bladder of non readers.
You can't turn that towards,
you know,
I want to Greg Fitzsimmons to see this.
Greg,
you recognize all those were
all best shoe at territory's.
Remember that we had this college agent,
great guy,
but he used a book us in the
middle of fucking nowhere.
He'd always call me Billy Scott Bass
calling half a Gig for you in Rhinelander,
Wisconsin.
Now they don't have a lot of money,
but I can build around it
and then he won't be stage.
It's at 12 noon in a hallway.
Can you do it?
Always take it.
And then I'd call,
I'm going to be yelling at him.
I'm never fucking doing
one of those gigs again.
Blah Blah.
And you would just fit on the
road sign and this is going.
Yeah,
you're will.
You're broke.
You're on a futon.
Guy Is an age
so sharp.
He's a,
he's in Chicago and I call him.
He's great dude.
I don't want to trash,
you know,
he's great,
but here's how sharp he is.
I called up and I go,
uh,
I go,
Louie CK needs a college agent.
And this is like,
Louie had already had a special ed too,
but he wasn't quite there.
And he goes,
he's too old.
I call it to this day going,
you fucking
and when you send them the map,
he kept getting them gigs in
like South Dakota and Wyoming.
He was living in New York.
He sent him a map of the United
States and circled Manhattan.
He goes,
I lived here.
They could never get us a Gig in New York.
Barry Katz at an all fucking sewn up.
Oh my God,
Christ.
And I got,
I got a Gig in Grand Junction,
Colorado.
Dude,
I remember he had half asleep driving
like 90 in the wrong direction in Colorado
trying to make this fucking gig and this
dude and like a Bronco drove right at
me with like a little blue light.
Pulls me over.
He gets out all he has on his,
the cop shirt,
he's got it like jeans and and no hat and
he walks up and he punches the window.
He goes out like yelling at me.
I'm like,
is this guy going to fucking shoot me?
So fucking lunatic.
And then I had to turn around to
go up to where the fuck Greeley,
where they really a good guy.
They got a fucking a w when
they slaughter pigs and shit,
they actually had bad smell days,
whether you call the
slaughter house and be like,
Hey,
can you take it easy?
A little slow it the smell,
it dries my daughter cry.
Can you do it?
I can build around it.
Yeah,
I got you at noon in Wisconsin that night.
North Dakota.
It's a nine hour drive,
but if you leave right after the Gig,
they give you the check beforehand.
You can make it,
sorry,
this is just getting so inside the last,
so just dropping,
dropping,
forcing me into a Gig.
I was going to say,
hang on there talking about these gigs.
She's like,
they're the old days.
We just both played a fucking,
see how she,
two weeks ago she food
restaurant in Fayetteville.
Fucking Arkansas sign.
There's a sign next to the
restaurant and it says three dogs.
I got once we,
I did one in Cheyenne,
Wyoming.
They had a drive through liquor store
that was connected to a strip club.
So you're looking in and you're
seeing the dances walking around.
The guy says,
sly look,
and I get for you
for the record.
The drive throughs in was
you can get a mixed drink in
Wyoming and a drive through,
but they put a cover on
the drink and put tape.
So
wait,
it's a sealed beverage
by the way.
There's 30 minutes of me doing this
oyster shack in four weeks ago
with Joe and I.
He started out in a club called Nick's
comedy stop that may or may not have been
mob run and the back of the club was
prostitutes cause it was in the red light
district.
They'd come in out of the coal and cops
shoulder to shoulder watching comedy.
That was a crazy place.
Yeah,
I missed all the good days.
It's by the time I got there it
was like the whole boom was over.
Yeah,
I did a Shitty Gig once.
It was a one and done Boston comics.
We're never going to
get a word in edgewise.
Remember Lenny Clarke
shout over your sport coat.
[inaudible].
Lenny's brother,
Mike Clarke booked me on a ton of gigs
and one of them was in a restaurant and
it was a seating area.
It's like the area where people see it
and waited for the name to be called this
giant fish place down in the Cape and
your sound system on stage was connected
to the,
the closer the wire system course it was
so the PA system and they said they all
use this same speaker but they would
override you so you'd be in the middle of
doing a joke.
Then John 10 party and the table's ready.
Johnson too afraid
to go back in again a second time.
It was a one and done.
I did a Gig at a red lobster
like a Sunday night and it was all
these bibs on and shit and we're in the
corner.
We just on this little roped off corn,
hey fucking fuck,
fuck fucking into this mic.
And he's just looking over like,
what is that?
Is that part of the restaurant?
It was just like,
no,
you weren't angry waiter and you wanted
to laugh at the person going on in front
of you,
but like you couldn't get
past the fact of like,
I have to do that in 10
minutes when he's done,
that's going to be me.
So you can never totally fucking enjoy it.
But anyways,
Trump has 2002
0.3 and Clinton has 1.8 in Ohio.
Oh my God.
Holy Shit.
He's going to win Ohio.
I was just in Dayton last week.
That doesn't help plug help.
That's
a good barometer.
This is honestly when I made it in
comedy was when I could turn down Dayton,
Ohio,
Lisa Grigsby.
That's number one.
That was my thing.
When I sit down,
fuck you guys.
Okay,
I don't wait.
And they papered the room.
Everybody should [inaudible]
status and the paper,
the room,
those are like the worst
words you ever want to miss.
Misread my contract.
And I got in the car after
Bob and Tom and I go,
how's the week look?
And they go,
fucking fantastic.
Were oversold on every show.
And I went,
when did I blow up?
And then we got there and they were like,
yeah,
the paper,
the whole room and no
one paid for tickets.
And I was like,
motherfucker,
I get 75% of nothing.
Are there comedians,
comedians in the house?
If you're here,
that the front room of jokers in Dayton,
Dayton,
home of the ultimate Bachelorette party,
which is the death knell of comedy,
but they sell and they
would sell dildo hats.
Oh Shit.
Oh,
horse fucking club draws the second you
saw him with the Little Dick Straws.
You just like this fucking show.
It's going to be brutal.
I got to hang in there
for 45 fucking minutes.
You know some people need a sitcom.
I just needed a never have to work
date men had rubber vagina hat.
Imagine the brutal outrage dudes
running around licking fake pussy.
Yeah,
probably look a lot like Donald Trump.
I need a cigarette anyway.
Hey,
this is how this goes.
We have no fucking idea how this goes,
but we're going to
rotate a bunch of people.
You don't have to discuss this.
I think they get it,
but I'm bringing someone in and
watching a shit show on to Jim.
Jefferies brought his stupid baby buddies.
I didn't smoke on stage.
You don't bring babies,
Jeff.
Jeff Rose.
You know what?
He's not here.
I need to bring my cost in.
He probably wants to say shit,
but I gotta have him on stage.
Chad Shag.
Yeah,
Garber for me.
I'll tell him,
by the way,
I will keep,
you want to browse?
Oh,
the kids
stays in the picture.
Okay.
I don't think this is the right kind
of air for this child to be British.
Hey Jim.
Jim Jeffery's
board kid.
Hide the dry.
I was just driving by with my kid and
I popped it in very quickly and he's
being,
you can go and sit on my lap.
Do I come and sit on my lap?
Don't let the kids touch the booze.
Yeah,
it's all right.
This is legal.
These fucking these kid.
Hey,
I think we just violated the new laws.
This is like that Hillary commercial
where they had the little kids watching
politics.
Bullshit.
Little kids don't watch politics.
There you go.
It's all about the future.
Oh,
I'm not comfortable with this.
You're not comfortable
with what we're doing.
Trump's Trump's winning New Hampshire.
Hillary's winning Virginia.
Really?
And there's a little kid here
decided it was good idea.
Somebody please take a
photo of this last supper
here.
Here's my phone.
I think this is the lead.
I don't want that on.
Why is it illegal?
What's illegal about this?
Having a baby on stage while people
are drinking booze and smoking pot.
We're fucking,
what am I crazy?
I would've been good to stay off Mike.
Oh,
they've got,
there's some legality problems.
Ah,
yeah.
Hey,
it's Brad Williams up here.
Why not?
Huh?
We're going to go everyone.
Sorry about that.
Sorry for losing the liquor
license comedy store.
Uh,
yeah.
Just try.
How's Australia looking at this point?
This shit.
Sorry.
All right.
We'll see you guys say
about Jim Jefferies.
Lazy Gentlemen.
All right.
Captain questionable judgment.
That was about as comfortable as
putting a condom on at an orgy.
Got It.
That's a good fucking line
line of the night so far.
I think that's totally illegal,
right?
Thank you.
And have a fucking baby
while people are talking
about eating fake pussies.
Be responsible for that.
I didn't.
We shut up
Jesus fucking Christ.
Awesome Mike.
Dude,
he's like every contract or every work.
Hold on.
My kids are calling.
Hey,
why don't you guys come down?
Oh Shit that happened.
Thank God.
Before the child came out.
Agreed,
agreed.
We all,
you all saw it.
Jesus.
Great.
There you go.
So what does it mean?
It definitely did,
but joints right there.
I got to say these pictures.
This is the best picture Donald Trump.
Best Picture of Hillary Clinton and
best picture of the other guy I've seen
throughout this entire thing.
Donald actually has a nice smile.
Hillary looks nice.
You know,
cause he always made them
look like fucking lunatics.
Did you guys see the picture of
Donald watching his wife vote?
A lot of trust in that relationship.
That's the same look I give my dog
when he gets too close to my cat.
Okay,
well what are you doing mother fucker?
Leave her alone.
Okay.
Oh,
I got way too high for this podcast.
You know that thing that
you have to do to dogs.
You have to do that to dogs.
Dogs,
you have to be their best friend,
but you have to love them to death.
But every now and then you got to go,
hey bitch,
he hit him.
Just go,
listen motherfucker.
If you don't,
the eat your cat,
right?
Hey,
look who's back.
Update time.
They've called Ohio 18
electoral votes from Ohio.
Go to Donald Trump.
Oh Shit.
There you go.
Okay,
so I've got to be a few
happy people here tonight.
You know this,
this isn't good.
This isn't a good barometer of America.
Come on Hollywood and sunset.
Yeah.
Can we all agree this
doesn't fucking work.
I mean,
you can't have one guy
wholesale,
right?
Hey d,
you can't have one woman.
You can't have one.
Anybody run the whole thing?
It's fucking crazy.
It's some crazy alpha chimp position.
We should have got rid of this
fucking stupid job a long time ago.
It's not how you should ever run anything.
You should never have one fucking person.
Ladies and gentlemen,
the most important.
Burn
me.
You fucked.
I run this bitch.
That's a crazy position.
Nobody should have that
position and most importantly,
nobody should want that fucking position.
Yeah,
but doesn't the Senate representatives
and it's at the balance there.
They keep checks and balances.
Vaguely remember that for my history
class and like fifth grade and then they
send it to the thing.
I'm just a bill.
Yes.
I'm only a bill and it goes to the thing.
Right,
and they fucking go around.
Congratulations Bill.
Now you're a law.
That's what keeps them in check.
Yeah.
I think the school schoolhouse rock,
I think we should vote on the Internet.
I think we should vote on
everything on the Internet.
I think everybody should collectively
decide what the fuck we should be doing.
The guy that was driving
me an Uber tonight,
I go,
you fall the election and he goes,
yeah,
a little bit.
I said,
really?
He goes,
yeah,
when did,
when did those start
today?
And he goes,
how long has it lasts till I go to today?
What is it?
Here's my question.
Ready lasts for like five fucking days.
It's so complicated.
He said a little bit,
literally meant a little bit.
I want to be that guy,
dude,
that's a fucking great guy to beat.
You know it is.
If you're all right with it.
Just like once the election.
Well,
I thought how long does it last?
Really?
I thought he was
driving is don't give a shit.
Literally it was like a how so how do
you get set up in to do and being able to
vote and I want it when you get a
little driver's license and Mike,
you're driving fucking Luber,
you definitely have a driver's license.
And then he goes,
who's,
I probably did that.
And I go,
yeah,
but he had dark hair and big eyebrows.
So I said the valley.
So I go,
so where are you?
Where did you,
where were you born?
And he goes,
if fucking van Nuys.
And I was like,
are you really don't
know anything about this.
He's like,
not anything
like,
why do we do it this way?
I gotta tell you something,
dude,
if Trump wins,
this is the him just winning the,
the nominee blows away.
Anything I've ever seen in sports.
The US beating the Russians.
It's just all pales in comparison.
This is a reality TV show star
who got mad at a breakfast because
Obama trash to him and he's like,
well fuck it dude.
He's going to do it
like it or not.
That is some,
you can't talk shit in
the room with that guy.
Yo.
One time this guy stepped
me in the bar to fuck you.
What time the president was
giving me shit and I said,
Oh yeah,
I'll have you a fucking job.
And two years and I did it
and I did it.
Fucking real man.
Don't like his policies.
But you gotta respect the Jesus.
Hey Bill.
If you want someone to go on stage with
you and just sit on a stool and laugh,
I'll do it.
Yeah.
So is this
the fate of our nation that
those little gray areas,
those bitches that like
this is always what happens?
Does the red guys do well in the middle?
The blue people do all
right in the beginning,
right?
But the east coast and all of
a sudden they get into the SCC,
right.
Going to be swapping some pain.
Then the red guys start coming back.
Then,
uh,
then,
then you get,
hey man,
you start getting near
the fucking ocean man.
And like I live near her notion,
therefore I'm smarter man.
That comes around and then
it gets a little more blue.
So this saying over all by a long shot,
ladies and gentlemen,
we shall see.
It's just so,
let's say they shitting on CNN right now.
If you're watching at home,
you want to put on CNN,
you got to watch the channel
where they're losing.
That's the funny shit.
Happiness is not enjoyable.
You want to see nervousness.
Beads of sweat.
Blue ties me in high.
Wouldn't you like to take a peek at all
the comics from the UCBS Twitter right
now?
Oh,
oh God.
They're fucking over dramatic
Hashtag I'm with her.
Oh Huh.
Do you love anymore?
Anyone can do it.
Can you get Gary Johnson on the phone?
Yeah,
yeah,
right.
Yeah.
10 Times more Twitter followers.
Yeah,
but he's not,
he's like,
he's CNNS bitch now already
got like 9% of the vote.
Just from your Twitter followers.
Oh,
fuck me.
No,
I'm kidding you about
him being CNNS bitch.
I voted for him,
but uh,
I couldn't get them know Arizona's pink.
Who's busy
sort of a bandaid color.
I don't know what that means.
Is that the whole fucking election?
That's Photoshop my space.
That's what bill [inaudible].
It's all lit.
It's lightened up.
It was like,
what did she look like this back in
the 90s that's like one of those mall
portrait photographers in
front of a shitty fake.
That's a fucking great photo.
So does anybody,
what is the numbers here?
One 67 for Donald Trump won
2140 to 70 she's 103 away.
Hope but he's kicking her ass.
I know,
but it's great.
It's Obama was,
did he ever call you?
Did he ever check in on
you to make sure you okay.
At the end of the day,
it's on you.
Who's packing your lunch tomorrow?
People.
You are who's putting food on the table?
You are all right.
You don't need these fucking people.
Yeah,
it's fine.
Having said that,
this is amazing.
Look at Michigan.
He won Michigan 49% she's got 45% this
is going to take the fucking hook and
lateral statue of liberty and a hail Mary.
He's the head.
He's the head by two
points is going to win.
Huh?
Think he's going to win.
Yeah.
It's entirely possible.
Or Fuck I told you.
Why don't we get to San
Francisco and all of them,
man.
We'll see what happens.
They saved the Toric Lens for the
end so they didn't build it up
and slide it out right in the beginning.
Are you saying there's a
Goddamn conspiracy son?
The conspiracy is that
we still do it this way.
Why don't we just have
everybody have an opinion?
Well,
you know we don't have a coach and buggies
across the country.
Joe.
How many down the road?
Too long to believe that
everyone should happen at Amazon.
One Click,
how come I can't vote like that?
I can buy toilet paper.
They deliver it to your house
in a day with one click.
I could bank
your bank.
You could just,
you can do whatever you want.
You can pick up on line.
I don't give a shit.
Yeah,
I did it online.
It's crazy money online,
but you can't handle votes.
That's ridiculous.
I bought a car part of it.
They took out a thing.
They wanted to take my thumbprint
when I my fingerprints,
you freak out and I was like,
yeah,
I'm not doing that.
I go,
why would I do that?
And they go,
well,
she's just took your notes to protect you
in case somebody comes in and a person
they choose to buy a car.
It's just like,
yeah,
I want to take my on that
fucking moron.
I'm going to get my fingerprint
to a car dealership.
You guys are the biggest
liars in the world,
so you can just pick it on some date.
Rape victims forehead.
Oh No,
I just want a Chevy cavalier and my name.
Oh,
there's no jail time on that.
That's just payments.
Got to pay for an escort gt.
Are you one of those guys?
It's free to use a thumb
sensor on your cell phone.
Do you have like an older cell phone?
I'm not afraid.
I'm just,
I just don't do it.
No.
Two or three skin man.
What's the phone to do?
No,
I don't use your cloud.
I dropped my phone in a fucking
toilet and I lost everything.
I lost all my videos,
all my numbers,
everything.
Cause I don't use the fucking
cloud whenever they say,
is it okay if we,
you know,
see you location?
No,
it isn't.
When I go to those things and they go,
hey,
you want a little savy saved card?
I say,
no,
I don't fuck off.
And whenever they ask me questions,
if I'm in the mood to answer,
I give them misinformation.
I go all over the place.
All over the place.
You should
relationship.
I like deer hunting.
I just got back from Antarctica.
Anything just to throw them off the scent.
What's your mother's maiden name?
Whoa.
Barney Miller.
Big Fan.
So why would you help him?
Okay,
that's a good point.
It's undeniable
recoveries.
No,
I got to quit.
I have a great Facebook page.
It's so great.
I almost stood up to tell it to you.
They fucking,
I go to change my password
because I'm so sick of my,
you know Kevin,
58 of them.
Right.
And I'm like,
when I just pick three,
it just stick with that.
So I go,
all right,
I'm going to change it.
Then all of a sudden
they send me an email.
They go,
yeah,
we lock this shit just
in case it is in you.
But if you want it,
you got to send us a picture of you
and like your fucking task court.
And it's just like,
yeah,
go fuck yourself.
I'm not doing that.
So for like a week I couldn't do it.
And then after like 10 days,
it was cool to be back on it
again cause it kind of like,
oh he's not coming back.
We,
we need them,
we need them.
So we clicked on revenue and
top 10 were celebrity boob jobs.
So we make our money.
How come they needed a 10 days ago,
Joe?
And all of a sudden
they don't need it now.
And I'm on Facebook again.
Why is that
point as well?
You're making some great points.
I am.
I'm making tremendous points and
I hear the sarcasm in your voice.
No,
no.
He goes down.
Oh,
me smokes a little fucking
weed and all of a sudden I'm,
I'm the Moron in the rock.
Oh,
I haven't said that.
I still need that shoulder workout.
You don't telling me about him?
I worry about the fingerprint thing.
It's weird.
You put Gary Johnson,
just one Puerto Rico.
Okay.
Powerful.
Puerto Rico.
Puerto Rico is like one strange child
that you had with your mistress,
so you don't really like to talk about,
but you give them money.
They're not really,
it's more like a beautiful child
that we have hidden the attic.
Well that's,
that's probably a better
description you're writing,
but they're not really a state,
right.
They both,
they're a part of the United States.
People that were enjoying their lives
and then we showed up I think is what
happened,
but there and shit.
I don't think they want to be a state.
No idea.
Good.
Yeah.
Look at Pico,
but it's one of those weird ones
like Guam where you're like,
what's going on?
Aware where,
who owns this?
Since you guys or is it us?
Who is this
breaking news?
Doug was Stan hope with breaking news.
You know,
I know John King's pretty
good at this on CNN,
but he doesn't fucking
bar back at the same time.
I just want to say that
he probably doesn't get tipped out either,
but on bar back in this fucker,
uh,
Virginia 13 electoral votes
go to Hillary Clinton.
That means
let's start one 67 for
Trump won 22 for Clinton.
Ooh.
Oh,
sandals.
States are common,
everybody.
The bargain sites.
It's a common,
this is going to be close.
Hey,
Rogen,
do you want to be,
I know it's a bit early,
but,
hey,
how you doing?
How are you man?
Should we just bust his balls
now before he takes off?
Who smells
really?
Oh,
oh.
Can I kill you?
Introduce him.
They all just run ad nauseum and I fucking
love him and he's the only person on
this day that I could call and go.
He's still more second pathic than I am.
Chad chank was napping,
but Marilyn Manson,
Jay,
you're fucking stinky ass.
No,
no,
you don't have to leave.
Matt will bring you a mic.
This show is going so
much better than we had.
High.
Go quick.
We don't need it.
We were barely talking
about the end of the world.
He doesn't want to come up,
but he's sitting right
there and then come on out.
I'll print the entire crowd
crowd.
Yep.
No,
I'm going to get another Jameson.
clearly is a gentleman that
might be the funniest men alive.
He's up there is him and Diaz.
It's in the running of this.
My,
this has been the hardest.
I've laughed in my life and I,
I been,
I know people don't like my last hope.
I've been a microwave from my mouth
because I cannot shut the fuck up.
Love your lab.
What are you talking about?
It's like my favorite thing about you
and this night couldn't be better.
Where were you when you found out
that Trump was running for president?
I was doing cocaine with Marilyn Manson.
What a fucking night.
Hello?
I'll let Ridley,
we have another state that is declared
Colorado nine electoral votes.
Go to Hillary Clinton.
Oh,
it's getting hot.
One 67 for Trump won
31 for Hillary Clinton.
Wow.
Look at this whole thing is so bizarre.
Is anybody like rooting for anybody
to come back and Christ
you to keep laughing?
That's all.
And Joey Diaz,
but he'll be here eventually.
What do women want Hillary Clinton to win?
Okay.
Oh,
some of you do.
Some of you do.
I'm going to watch those
girls very carefully.
Give a fuck camp.
Here's
weird.
You opened up smoking a joint up here,
but Jim Jeffries got bailed
out as you can't have a kid
near.
We have a list as a part of the show.
Nobody knows it joint.
Can you just fucking ratted me out?
I never even talked about it earlier.
The cigarettes get the fuck out.
No,
you're all right.
You're allowed to smoke
on stage and California.
No,
but then the smokers see you smoking
and then they want to go outside.
Oh Hey,
real quick,
what?
I want to interject,
what's going on with
prop 64 is that the is
is that,
I think it's kind of halfway sketchy.
He's calling you.
What'd you there?
Hang that shit up.
He's a grown man.
He's right there.
Tell him to come out here.
How dare they said?
Come on out here please.
Calling you.
Fuck with beautiful man guy.
My sanity today.
Oh,
now,
now they're doing
interventions on Madison.
Bert Kreischer Friday night showtime.
Is it 11:00 PM
no,
10:00 PM 10:00 PM I keep
saying 1111 oh my God.
Yo.
I was in such a panic
tonight for other reasons.
I took an Adderall.
I go,
I think I took this too late.
I'm going to walk down.
I'm busting Manson's balls like,
well,
it's a block away.
We can just walk like fucking men.
I'm manning up.
I'm putting on a fake comedy face to do
this shit under extreme circumstances.
You can walk down here and I know he's
going to get on stage and you know it's
going to be on stage.
You think it's happening.
I can go on and on and on,
but it's going to be funny because I
thought the dynamic of Manson and Rogan,
you'd be so treacherous.
It was.
It was alarmingly like,
uh,
like almost like a high school reunion.
Joseph's while somebody goes,
hey man,
we met one time and it was like the
coolest fucking thing in the world.
Oh thanks bill.
Boom.
You were there.
Cheers by day.
There's no proof that our pod cast
what Manson at his house with Bingo.
No.
You know what's funny?
Both you and him said that
and you were so fucked up.
You don't remember.
I wasn't there.
Yes.
He's,
he's claimed for 20 minutes
that we've met each other.
I've never met him.
Were remember I was right
as I was going to say,
huge fan.
He goes,
yeah,
I remember that time we
will fucking hanging out.
I was,
no,
no.
I don't remember.
I would've remembered that
I'm,
Nancy was looking it up in his phone,
but I wasn't there after that.
I came out when when they save party,
like a rock star.
He's the only rock star that
really parties to like a rock star,
so I'm trying to keep up.
Okay.
Do Your podcast.
That's right.
I'm sorry.
Yeah,
you're right.
You're right.
As fucked as I've ever been.
I'm wearing that leisure shoot.
Remember the leisure suits,
they all kind of blend together.
Jackets,
shorts,
matching.
I Hennigan pulls me out of bed with like
30 minutes sleep bingos in a fucking
crazy state.
Air B and B.
I tell Hennigan,
put the top down.
We're going to your place
on the fucking sticks.
You both,
I can do the valley shit.
I show up and I was judging
in reeking of booze.
We were talking about this earlier when
when you feel the heat coming off of you
and you just think that's your imagination
and then you put your sunglasses on
and they fog up.
Oh fuck.
And I'm already seriously intimidated by
Bob Burg and I'm doing his podcast and
I show up.
I'm smelling bad.
The sound went out.
I didn't know what I was talking about.
It's far as I remember.
It went great.
I remember saying,
I never realized what a
bundle of nerves you are.
What are you going to stand
in the mirror and say,
God damn,
I love you Doug Stam home.
You're a genius comedian and
you're worthy of all your success
now.
[inaudible].
The end of that story is
after bill's burrs podcasts,
he came to my house and he came and he
and Andy Hill was hammered.
I don't remember any of this and he came
early cause he thought birth podcast to
be three hours and it's an hour.
And then he comes to my house and my dogs
are sniffing at my door and I'm like,
what the fuck?
I opened the door,
Doug's sitting in one of
my Adirondacks shaking,
smoking a cigarette and looks at me.
He goes,
I could use a cocktail.
Yeah,
we did a five hour podcast interrupted
only to have dinner with my children.
I was one of the best things
my life after I got done with Berg,
I went to his house and I was a new drunk
now and now it's the next night even
though I haven't slept.
It's kind of like a new day.
I have,
he's got the kids.
He's got his own fun house.
Yeah.
And the garage.
The man,
my man cave that they,
the TV show did that for you,
right?
Yeah.
Yeah,
man caves.
That's why I called him.
If I walked into a locker room,
it was all black guys and they were like,
look at that cock.
I call my digger cock all the time.
So yeah,
it was a man.
The man caves did it.
It's the best thing that
ever happened to me.
Well,
how do those two sentences connect?
I Dunno.
I know I'm not alone here.
Right?
I'm high,
but I'm not retarded.
I don't like this.
Sometimes you just got to nod with birth.
It's weird how quickly he
turns it to black cock.
You know,
like no matter what the topic is,
so it's finding the house threatening.
Oh,
fear is funny.
It's always been funny.
Fucking always wobbling.
Joe.
Speaking of beer,
rule of Holy Shit.
Is he going to win?
Pennsylvania know we're
out of the ass is funny.
That's the first rule of comedy.
Yeah.
Back in the day.
Oh,
this is a scary,
it's Pennsylvania's looking mostly red.
We got to get Donald Trump on mushrooms.
We can turn this bitch around.
Yeah,
we did turn this bitch around.
Pennsylvania has not been called,
but it is right now.
49% Clinton,
47% Trump outside of a child molester.
A murder is not irredeemable.
Right?
This is certain Polina,
bring them back.
Just six six to 10 dried
grams in an isolation tank.
Donald,
we don't,
we don't ask a lot of you,
but we asked this one journey
show on my phone.
I'm just seeing what man's instruct.
Any fucking idea how awesome that
would be if we get Donald Trump trippin
where are you?
Feed Go.
I'm so sorry,
but look,
now we can fix it.
We can all fix it together.
We're
us now.
Not then.
Have you given up?
No,
I haven't given up a
view like this is fun.
People are fun.
I love people.
Life is awesome.
Even if the things bullshit,
I voted.
It's probably bullshit.
This will be the first time
I didn't vote for the winner.
Oh yeah.
I voted for the winter every time.
That's right.
Bush twice
money on board once.
I don't know how many times he did it.
Well,
if you'd have really voted for the winter,
you would have voted
for Gore the first time.
No,
I take that back.
That's the only time I didn't
vote and I was on a TV show,
the x show,
and I said out loud on this TV.
I was like,
my vote doesn't count.
I'm not voting.
Everyone don't vote besides,
it's a right in vote from
Florida and literally
actually counted,
but not in bed by 86 or something.
But
you ruined the future that is now
Al Gore won by a half a million
votes in the popular vote.
That's how you know the system's broken.
That's how a lot of fucking people,
a half a million people die in a fire.
And it's the worst tragedy
in American history people.
Yeah.
You know what I'm saying?
But at half a million,
that's a lot of fucking human beings
chose him over Bush and our system's so
fucked up that it doesn't recognize that
discrepancy that somehow or another,
your patch of dirt is more significant
than you as an individual and us as a
collective that can share ideas.
It's more important to have fucking
electoral college bill burr.
You're witty retort.
I don't know.
I understand what you're saying.
I agree.
I agree with that.
They day,
I don't like how the
coast looked down on the,
on the Midwest.
Ridiculous.
They're morons.
They grow our food supply.
They're not dumb and they have the
internet now go to trader Joe's.
What do you,
what do you,
what do you think that
food comes from exactly?
Huh?
Comes from Joe Sixpack,
California.
What's his fucking pants
on one leg at a time,
right?
Yes.
Truck who keep with this and drivers.
The drunk driver food mostly comes from
Jose six pack if we're talking about
shit.
That's true.
Oh,
it isn't love slide.
We got ourselves a liberal
here
with the barest meant
for your political views.
I see.
More blood and less avatar blue dude.
That's good.
You got to have the blue right.
What was the hood is at Rhode Island.
That's Milwaukee County.
Milwaukee County ever Lee,
the county.
Milwaukee.
Great River Lake.
Front property by the way.
Tremendous dude.
You wait,
you wait till the fucking global warming
or keep one in the golden age of it
right now.
If you're going to,
everyone's going to want
to live in Milwaukee,
Wisconsin,
live on a load.
Remember Silver Lake?
Where did that go?
We put it up for a while.
Crazy rent to me.
We put it out of the,
and it's a crazy,
it's not there.
I'm always call crazy.
I said the fucking NBA was fixed
every law and order your fucking mind.
They get a mobbed up rep.
It was a lot.
It's just one.
Just one.
I said Kennedy got shot.
I know.
It's just one guy my whole life.
Lee Harvey Oswald Guy.
Do you think Lee Harvey Oswald acted
alone or you think it was a conspiracy?
I don't fight.
I don't.
I can't.
There's too much shit to read.
This is what this is so long ago,
Bill,
too many people with have their
eyebrows up when they talk about it.
It just makes me okay.
Comfortable
to want to fucking just sit
here and tell me what you think.
You know,
I'll listen to a fun when you get into
that like hamster emerging energy,
like you're running on a wheel.
I don't want to be around you.
It's an amazing picture of Hillary.
Couldn't I swear to God?
I would actually accept a hug from her.
Fucking hilarious.
If she just had that
oh seven hours ago,
I wouldn't vote for it.
Now I'm looking at it like I want,
I want to make me some cookies.
Should it be for a second?
Donald Trump tire salesman that had the
heart attack and everybody's fucking
upset.
He was great with the community.
They crushed it with the A
to wolf blitzer is not from this planet.
He doesn't.
He does not look like anybody.
Wolf,
the cute little car that
could around the corner.
One 94 Clinton won 71 for Trump.
Well,
what else?
You got California?
Yeah.
Oh,
she's a head now.
It's a crazy little cartoon race.
Come to Bergen stocks
will be all 23 skidoo.
Oh,
here we go.
The old razzle dazzle play.
We got Oregon and fucking
does Alaska matter.
Jesus Christ,
those poor fuckers.
By the time they cast their vote,
they get done having their
fucking grizzly bear.
Fucking bill tails worked up there.
Yeah,
this fucking
girl
is.
We still work there.
I booked up there.
Fucking here's dude.
That fucking comedy Condo
was what was an abomination?
That fucking bed,
that fucking bed for the audience.
Duct stand.
Hope that fucking beds.
The only guy that ever got a
hotel there because he was so bad.
No,
we're afraid the floorboard wrong.
Wrong,
wrong was so weak.
They were afraid he'd
go through Donald Trump.
Wrong,
right,
wrong.
My wig coming off.
Hang on.
The fucking bed was already broken dude.
It was fucking,
no,
it was enhanced jelly.
This is the guy that
actually booked you there.
It was the worst ever match.
The bed was fucking
broken and I just looked at it going like,
fuck,
I guess this is paying your comic dues.
And I got into this block.
You had to make it yours.
It was disgusting.
The gig was great,
but the fucking comedy Connor was horrible
and Ralphie may taught me a lesson
cause I went down and laugh factory.
I said,
yeah,
I just did Chilkoot Charlie's right.
And he goes,
Oh yeah,
I did that kick.
I go do it.
How about that fucking comedy Condo?
How was that fucked up?
He goes,
dude,
I didn't stay there.
I told him to get me a
hotel and I was like,
you could do that.
You can say I'm not
fucking standard out here
to vouch for me.
They were so afraid to tell you something
you that they wouldn't tell Ralphie
that they would just,
the bed was broken.
The bed was already broken.
Course it was not because
of Ralphie lawsuits,
because they know what did
Ralphie break that bed?
All these years I've been mad at Alaska.
We do a thousand horrors
and fucking thousand horse.
Just people.
I'm just saying that
bed was fucked up quick.
Corey actually prop acted.
I brought a bar of soap from the band
house and chill to Charlie's on stage
because it had black mold on an
anti bacterial product and I go,
you guys think I'm kidding
about how bad this is?
They have mold.
You didn't tell me that when
you booked me on the Gig
did ya?
I thought it was funny.
I still do.
That's what being quite sure.
Still Worth Oyster shacks in Fayetteville,
Arkansas.
I did Chilkoot Charlie's and all
I will say is that the bartender,
who's your good friend?
Uh,
the owns a place.
What's his name?
Joe Ran?
No,
the Becker.
Becker.
Becker just didn't laugh at me once,
but just kept nodding and smiling and
sending shots to the stage and I got so
blackout drunk.
He was like time to go to the bus company
and it's a strip club where if you
like,
they will put your Dick in
their mouth through your genes.
I didn't do it
but I'm on man.
Rumor has it,
it feels just like it.
Rogan had you,
you had to shoot
pants idea.
No,
that wasn't even mine.
It was a friend of mine actually.
Did it.
He would take,
you know those plastic Nike Pants.
Remember the nine days,
those pants?
No,
there were like workout pants for some
reason we thought it'd be a good idea.
We did.
And we're like thin nylon workout pants
and the nineties remember who you are.
Well that's how I know Joe.
Well this,
we all wore those.
So this dude,
I know he took sandpaper to the
crotch shot of these things.
Just he got us to where he could see
how many fingers he had up in front of a
light and then then he
shaved his cock and balls,
looped it all up,
no underwear,
put these things,
got lap dances and so I'm there.
And then he created you?
He told me.
Okay.
He used to call it shooting.
What do you call it?
Shooting.
Cause she naked women sit on your lap.
He just squirt in his
pants and it was like,
all right,
I'm good.
It's us.
It's a loophole.
These are the smart guy.
He didn't hurt anybody.
It was an even exchange of money.
There was a lot going on.
We used to
Tampa,
we'd wear 'em bros.
What's an Umbro?
Amoebae,
Roser soccer shorts,
those real thin soccer shorts.
Oh,
18th birthday.
We're like gentlemen umbrellas.
We don't pull it up
and go a Mazda penis and just be like,
just try to take my pants
off with your pussy.
Here we go.
And they just grind on.
You look at her and you're like,
oh yeah,
it's not over,
but I'm done.
Huh?
It's a weird salamander rolling down your
leg or you imagine if there was clubs,
imagine it was clubs like that where
women could go and men would just climb on
top of him,
fucking squeeze on them and
Ooh.
Oh,
oh
my wife.
My wife went to the w.
It was,
it was,
oh,
I should not say this.
I'm going to say it.
Fuck it.
It was,
it was Christina push excuse,
Bachelorette party.
No,
you did it.
I should not have said that.
I should stop this story now.
The Australian snakes don't.
I don't give a fuck.
I'm sure she's honest with Tommy and
so they got a male stripper and my wife
called up and she goes,
hey,
they have a male stripper.
Should I get a lap dance in my head,
I'm like,
oh,
should we have been clearing
this with each other?
I know what a mail lap down.
I've seen it all like show like showtime,
you know,
or whatever.
HBO,
there's male lap dances and I
know my wife's not into that shit.
I go definitely,
definitely get a lap dance.
She calls back traumatized.
She's like,
he basically painted
my face with his cock.
Apparently.
Another,
another person that,
I won't name their name,
but this Guy Chris,
he didn't not get a lap dance,
but he would just dip male strippers.
Just smack 'em like this,
that with a rod deck.
That's what a fucking mail lap dances.
It's like,
fuck off.
That was his stage name.
That's his number one hit songs.
His website
with a Rod,
Dick Dope or ignite.
You're,
you're saying he's saying
an actual dicta face like,
I dunno if they got negative,
but they have those,
those drop on North
Carolina 15 electoral votes.
Back to the,
the storyline
I used to work out with this,
who used to wear,
he had like elephant.
He was,
uh,
he was a male stripper and he had
elephant underwear where there's like the
ears,
the elephant.
That truck was Dick.
Yeah.
It would go into like this little thing.
It was like a panty hose.
Those underwears have a,
um,
they have like a cock ring in them so
that your balls and Dick are in the front
of it.
It's actually great presentation.
What's that?
I know I was a male stripper for a day on,
on my,
one of my TV shows at as
Gay Strip club and uh,
and it,
you look much better than
you normally do cause you,
you're all your shits up front.
Like it's selling a car.
And so,
uh,
it's like a pushup bra fee.
A job.
Yeah,
exactly.
Exactly what it's like
pushup Bra for your time.
I deejayed one of those
fucking Bachelorette parties
one time and a guy came out
and the chick pulled his pants down and
he had fucking rubber band around his
cock and balls,
like a poor man's cock ring full on.
And he,
he went,
he went fucking crazy.
He was like,
fuck you,
you don't touch me.
And he went nuts because he just had
small package with rubber bands like just
paper.
I call them paper route.
He'll be there one day.
Oh,
I read a horrible
and how a guy cut his own dick off
online because it's just falls off in his
dick off.
And the way he did it was first
he killed it by tying it off.
So he,
he he documented it was the early,
early days.
The Internet when we
were just starting to go,
what the fuck I get in the the like the
late nineties early two thousands there
was a website called [inaudible].
It's like body modification,
extreme Mary,
you guys remember that time,
applause break and a shelf
applause break like bring it back.
Youth organization called friends
when the guy ran the site
was dead is dead now,
but he was into like really crazy shit.
Like yeah,
online friends who he sent me his book.
We used to send emails back and forth.
He's a very smart guy.
First email,
first of all is because
he site where people like,
yeah themselves up and cut
their dicks apart or whatever.
Yeah.
Like fifth for cares shits,
friendships start well because I was,
I wrote a blog,
I wrote a blog and I was mocking something
that someone did that was ridiculous.
Like some guy who grew his fingernails
or the longest in the world and he lost
control of his left arm.
Like his nerves died in his left arm
because he has these fingernails that are
like seven feet long
and he never cuts them.
And I wrote this whole thing about it
and this guy emailed me back about body
modification and it was like,
he's really intelligent
response just to let you know,
this is why people do weird shit.
Like this is the psychological
components of it.
I wrote a website,
they want to be a sponsor on your potty.
No,
no,
I had no podcast.
This was 1997
so anyway,
he,
the guys gives me a free password to his
site so I could see what's going on and
I just check out all these people that
are having these weird fucking bolts
screwed into the top of their head and
cut in their ears and split and their
tongues and doing all this freaky shit
and I go down the rabbit hole as you do,
you keep clicking links and I found this
one dude who decided he didn't want his
dick in his balls anymore.
He had some weird relationship with his
boyfriend was boyfriends like that Dick
is useless.
You're going to cut it off.
He's like,
yes,
master,
and he's this guy ties rubber bands around
his dick until there's no circulation
in his dick and balls.
It all goes black.
He photographs it and
takes a documented blog,
needs a rubber band and not
have circulation in their penis.
I think it's a different,
it's a cell death.
It's type of constriction
we're dealing with.
It's not as simple as a,
your dick doesn't get hard.
It's like as much more
complicated shit going on,
please necrosis.
Anyway,
the dude documented cutting off his own
cock and balls and like photos of the
video out.
No,
there was no video.
It was a vote.
It was photographs waiting for the
first communication where you go,
hey,
come on.
I know I'm a big fan of youtube.
No,
it was the guy who cut his balls off.
A number of similarities between
comedy and body modification.
We ought to get together
for a Latte at some point.
They don't believe in counting all
my comedy suppose elastic band.
This guy,
we're in the same business
or the Internet.
Are you on Joe?
Well,
this was the again is the 1990s yeah,
that's that.
Thank you.
Thank you very much.
You know?
Yes,
he's from Toronto.
Yeah.
Okay.
Split is on deck.
You're right.
See,
I'm not lying.
You guys think I'm fucking lion.
It's okay.
Can you,
I'm going to have any rules.
Can you say the [inaudible]
of his name just so I could,
hang on if we're going to talk,
talking to them like,
no,
no.
Go to my room.
You can hear a bro.
You're wearing flip flops.
This is disgusting.
It's trying to,
was trying to be healthy.
[inaudible] Hillary,
you liked the guy tried to talk to his
child and you're yelling out instructions
if the kid relaxed.
Yes,
please.
Yeah.
It's like Tom,
what would you say his
name though correctly?
Shit.
Shannon.
Laura.
Okay.
Thank you.
He's a really nice guy and he's passed,
right?
It's just like some all comic con.
This story.
It's about a guy.
Does anybody know one the names decided
to turn his Dick in one of those
ballpark Franks.
He left on this hot
dog thing for too long.
Guy Hated
his side circus and all
that fucking shit for care.
He had just hang himself and trees
with fucking giant hooks from his tit.
Everything.
Cars.
He sure figure it out.
They don't have to do
that to get attention.
There's other methods.
You can be a housewife.
What's that?
Gg Allen.
Yeah,
he's still sharp people.
That's unique.
I mean,
look,
you can say you don't like it.
You don't want to see it,
but it's not a lot of people doing it
and you should probably watch it once,
right?
It is a show.
We're guy throws shit dog.
Stand up.
Get out of here and tell a
story about extreme Elvis.
Hey,
do you have a,
do you ever feel like
the shit you shouldn't,
I look at like,
I look at your soul like it's pixelated
and every time you watched some shit
like that,
a couple of cubes float away.
I like the next day like a
peanut butter and jelly sandwich.
Justice just doesn't taste as well.
Like there's just certain shit.
You got to draw a line.
Okay.
We're all adults.
I'm not saying where the line is.
You got got to know
where your soul is wired.
Well you just gotta be like,
Dude,
you're like fucking deep cover
you watching some guy taking a,
you know I watch the food
network but it's an onion.
You're watching like fucking,
he's doing a little thing there where
you don't fucking cut your finger off as
he's slicing up
again,
this is the 90s were
talking about the nappies.
Excuse doesn't people nineties
the phrase were on your defense.
It was harder to find this shit man.
Ha ha ha,
thanks.
We're getting fucked up date.
Okay,
so the big thing right now,
what's going on is Pennsylvania.
She's up by 2% few fucking gets this
and then it gets to the Bergen stock.
Hey man,
like everybody.
Then you got a shot,
Tony,
ladies and gentlemen.
Well wait a minute.
For the Trump people in the corner,
you still got Montana.
You just feel guide Idaho.
You still got Wyoming.
You got Nevada and all of
them could form together.
They can all form together naked wash
over all them fucking hippies on the west
coast.
They can do that shit.
When this list was like a great SCC game,
it's burden.
Lunquist should be
fucking announcing this.
Trump wins the state of North Carolina.
Oh,
Trump rocked her.
I
Trumbull,
North Carolina,
North Carolina.
Dude,
this shit's over.
Everybody.
No,
we don't.
You dummy.
She's behind and she's,
she's up.
She's up.
She's a head writer at
walls already built.
You guys don't understand
how you been hanging out with
Oregon.
Goes to Hillary.
Hey man,
we wear sandals as hang out in
Coos Bay and watched the seals.
Man,
here it comes.
Here it comes.
Let's get some locally brewed
beer in some local oysters.
Yeah,
but Nebraska
just went to church.
You were serious shoes there.
All right,
everybody I breaking news.
There's a gentleman
in California.
Voters have passed the ballot
measure legalizing recreational
marijuana.
Dammit.
Can we go see what matters?
Not Your leader?
Yeah,
hold on.
It's right.
You might as well hit it now,
Bill.
Sure.
Hello,
ladies and gentlemen,
but finally a dolt.
Oh my God.
We're finally a dose
as much as this
fucking world.
Your life happened tonight.
Hold on.
What about the mandatory condoms in porn?
You can you look that up?
That's nonsense.
I want to see what that is.
We got it.
They took our jobs.
We've got to keep those jobs.
We got to keep those
jobs here in the valley.
All right.
Yeah.
Well,
to start it in the valley,
it stays here.
I changed my wife's mind on the condom
ballad in line with people behind us in
front of us.
She was on voting yes on this.
I go,
no,
no.
It's a no.
That means that all our porn stars have
to go to Arizona to find porns that I'll
watch.
She was like,
why?
When you watch one with a condom on?
Doesn't that I go,
it's fucking not you.
It turns you off.
Trust me.
Yeah,
it is a porn is a fantasy.
Yeah.
Nowhere in the fantasies
and then I put a condom on.
I was reasonable.
That's why we want,
it just doesn't quite
feel as good as it should.
Like I'm losing it
because I drank too much.
It's like super heroes.
They're like superheroes.
They do stuff we can't do our superhero.
Duncan Trussell.
I'm going to just say what he said,
cause it was really hilarious.
Duncan Trussell said,
well if they should pass laws should
be that men can't talk and pornos.
Yeah,
hit the mute button.
How many times do you hit the mute button?
I also say no.
Reversing nut shot,
man.
Too much nuts.
Oh,
for fuck sakes.
Yeah.
Right
to complain about with
your white privilege.
That's what you choose.
Too much nuts,
Joe.
First World problem,
Dude.
I used to jerk off back in the days
when men didn't shave their assholes.
Okay,
you watch a porno and
they'd show that back shot.
Especially if you were in a hotel room
in the Er in the 90s they weren't allowed
to show penetration.
You could even,
you couldn't even show genitalia.
Get him,
shoot.
You showed people fucking,
you knew there were fucking,
but you can never actually see
it going in and they showed,
yeah.
Hicks had a whole bit
about the heroes and ass.
There's a lot of rubbing
member that it'd be like,
oh,
remember that Hick Smith?
Do you remember the Hitch Smith?
No.
Michigan is 47.9 to 47.0
Trump.
Oh,
the suspense.
I enjoyed it.
I enjoyed the suspense.
You will,
not every word.
That's fucking Ted
Nugent land a course man.
Did you see him on there?
He's a motherfucker with an Arrow man.
Right
technique.
I mean it only winning by 0.9%
it's not some crazy blowout.
There's like 47% people.
I'm like,
I don't know.
You know?
Oh,
47.1 now she's the 1.8 shit.
But
uh,
this next comic,
oh,
Jesus just had a Twitter poll of who
should be bumped from this panel so he can
talk and resoundingly they'd
picked whoever needs to piss or
have a cigarette.
No.
What do you think I was picking on?
You
know I,
Brendan Walsh.
Oh,
Yay.
[inaudible]
Trump.
I love your elbow patches.
Thanks man.
I bought it downtown.
Sweet.
Yeah.
A hundred bucks suits
downtown baby Brendan Walsh.
Ladies and gentlemen can't
tell the difference either.
You cannot tell the difference between
a hundred dollars suit and $1,000 to
tell.
Again,
I'd never owned $1,000 suit,
but you've seen him.
I've seen him.
Hey,
you go.
Do you watch prosecuting attorneys?
Actually,
it's the,
the defense attorneys are the ones
with the fucking expensive suits.
See The da down at the
store buying $100 suit.
What's your predictions?
It's fucking,
I mean,
I'm all for comedy,
but this is too funny the way it's going.
It's so funny.
It's scary.
This is fucking riveting.
This is one of the,
this is tremendous.
Amazing is that on top of all the drama,
everybody in California just
got really fucking high.
They're all stone and
watching it right now,
like this is it.
Finally.
We don't have to feel like we're fucking
criminals for doing something that
doesn't even hurt you.
It's so stupid.
That leads to heroin and
fucking other things.
Best Gateway drug for me is alcohol.
I wonder if they're going to smoke weed
in pornos while not wearing condoms.
I Dunno if the condom thing has passed has
it,
but that's,
that's a good joke.
Is it weird if on the condom
thing I wrote in Gary Johnson
didn't really get an answer there.
I guess instead of
instead of using condoms,
you have to use Johnson weld.
It sounds like some kind of
Dick Repair Kit doesn't it?
Five seconds after what happened?
Who did you drop the trap?
Oh,
how dare you there.
I got it.
Mark,
Bert,
Bert.
All right.
Just to recap.
One 97 to one 87 Hillary,
Florida,
Michigan,
New Hampshire,
Pennsylvania,
Wisconsin.
Too early to call and other than that,
everything else is mustard color.
I feel like this was frozen.
Yeah,
this is frozen.
Frozen.
Okay.
Hey guys,
they're really committed to
that mannequin challenge.
It's been frozen for three hours.
I was like,
Wolf Blitzer is really
thinking about this point.
Huh?
True.
I said the funniest thing nobody got.
How do you,
how do you,
how do you reset this?
So you go like this?
Yeah,
that's it.
You're blowing your thought.
Well,
there's no fucking mouse.
There's nothing on this thing.
It's fucking sufficient.
Hi,
Trump won Florida.
Trump won New Hampshire.
You got Florida.
What does it say?
What's the score man?
Two 16 to one 97 Trump two
61 97 Brandon [inaudible].
He's got a kickoff to Hillary and
to his fucking old Washington.
Brendan Walsh.
I know you kind of a prankster,
but you're also a very smart guy.
Yeah.
Like
I know you did.
Would you be happier
if one of these people,
one and we were,
is this,
I mean,
you know,
this is,
this is shattering my world
because I'm such a conspiracy nut.
I just thought like they got fucking,
I was like,
well,
they want Hillary to be president,
so they got the craziest fucking monster
to run against her and now my whole
world's being shattered because it looked
like I've been wrong all these years,
that it's,
the elections aren't fucking
rig from top to bottom.
I think they,
they rig it to a certain extent,
but there's only so much they could
do without being really obvious.
Mean you can have.
Yeah,
because there's a bunch of
people that want to run it all.
They just can't get up,
get all,
get on the same page.
Trumps the one that said it was rigged
and now he's about to win this shit.
I know.
That's amazing.
But he kind of proved it was along the
way along with wikileaks exposing what
they did,
trying to do the forced
Bernie Sanders out.
Yeah.
Like they actively conspired in their
own party to keep this guy from winning.
Like they,
they're like,
fuck that dude.
I got to say all you pussies
who kept voting for Hillary
should have gone with Bernie,
should have gone party pussies.
Sarah Silverman was right.
That shit when they were like,
no,
if you actually believed in her,
fine,
but I just eat food.
But those people who were just like this,
no way this guy can win.
So you're going to vote for someone who
goes to those Bilderberg meetings when
they,
when they dress up like facets
and they fuck each other.
Yeah.
That's your fucking hope.
I got it.
Be Honest.
Is One clear way that I'm sexist.
I don't mind if someone
calls it due to Dick,
but like when you talk
about a pussy in a bad way,
like ah,
to pussy,
look what,
what is it about that that's
less Kona due to pussy?
Well,
anybody a pussy,
like pussies.
Pretty good.
Thanks.
But if,
uh,
if someone
says that guys up in Massachusetts,
you understand the terminology.
I do.
I understand it.
Are you trying to sick feminists on me?
That's not what I'm doing.
Joe Rogan tells Bill Burr Cassie,
how did it actually,
this may surprise you.
Here's why Bill Baer is wrong@salon.com
Tony edge lift.
Donald Trump's about to be
living in government housing.
Oh Shit,
Tony.
It's just the fact we're going to
have a gold plated White House soon,
son.
Okay.
How many times does that
motherfucker going to golf?
Okay.
This is what's really fucked up about
this whole thing is this fucking country
right now is painted so goddamn
red and Hillary still in it.
Somehow like this is fucking,
that's like when a team
has like nine turnovers,
but somehow there's still fucking losing.
It's like,
how was that possible?
I'm sorry.
Let me get to this crowd.
It's like when someone starts,
is that Dick up?
Listen,
ladies and gentlemen,
can't worry about a little joint.
It's free.
It's we,
it's we.
Now we're good here.
It's legal.
It's like you drop knowledge on,
I got on me fucking crazy.
Come on.
I wrote,
I wrote [inaudible].
Ladies and gentlemen,
we're here for the long haul.
This thing's going down right now.
Malik coming up,
whatever it means.
Dropping the joint is like a
hundred Mike drops at once.
It's a cool new thing since pot's been,
oh,
okay.
This is how it started.
Joint drops on the main rooms.
They just think I'm going to buy a hummer.
Trump lands,
I'm buying a fucking Hummer on.
I'll put those blue neon lights
and it's like he knew he
could be like a vampire.
Familiar.
You can live amongst them.
I'm just going to blend in,
man.
I'm going to blend in.
I'm gonna Start Wearing tank tops again.
Fuck Trump's in the house.
What's up?
No assholes on top of this fucker.
He's looking right now like
Pennsylvania is going to be the decider.
Jesus.
Those people were doomed.
Payway dot.
Clinton's cleanse,
not doing it.
Hold on.
Landed bear in 1700 and the fucking dumb.
He stayed.
Okay.
They're decided in our faith.
Why are you still there,
mother fucker?
You know about Oregon still?
One 97 187 hey,
could either of you guys explain what
you mean when you say Phyllis Delphia is
going to be that fill this
Delphia I am so fucked up.
Does anybody know how
many states there are?
Seriously,
guys?
Pretty sure Brooke Chrysler thinks
that Phyllis Diller is about
the election.
Oh,
Bill is?
Yeah.
Violated their minor league
here.
Here's some non condoms.
Oh,
that was amazing.
Hey,
throw that joined back.
You wasted so much weed that they're
about to legalize weed right now.
They got mad at you.
Just Hey,
I'm the new host of the man show.
Hey,
shut up.
Shut up.
Oh Shit.
This just in Canada is building
a wall across the u s border.
They're armed guards protecting
their country from assholes
moving their Tripoli hates,
uh,
Hinchcliffe.
I'm not,
I don't know the whole scene.
Who was Sam?
Truthfully?
Tony Hinchcliffe so much.
I know.
I'm just,
I'm making up bullshit.
Trying to bring high
right now Tripoli out.
Oh,
okay.
So I fucking threw you out.
I know.
I'm going to throw them out.
I can throw you out Sam Aaa Aaa.
Get out of here.
Oh.
Oh,
he's not even listening.
Sit back down.
Doug doesn't even have snap chat.
Billy's phone number.
This is a prank.
Brendan,
are you behind this?
Yeah,
behind everything.
It wasn't like you're correct.
Posture.
Aye.
Hype myself up and I said
Sam Tripoli.
There you go.
Typically he hates Tony Hinchcliffe
so badly we were over here.
Oh wait.
Oh you're,
I thought he was quite happy.
Election Day,
everybody.
Happy Election Day.
Sam Tripoli.
I had my wash set to the wrong time and
I go an hour and a half from here after
this.
So from here?
No,
it's two and a half more hours.
Condom loss.
Pat.
What happened that
that's what Sam Shipley's
concerned very much.
We've lost and condom la doing this
and we doing this like we're a bunch of
fucking baby.
It didn't pass.
Then they got to put the weed
on their dicks in pornos now.
What's that?
What?
They've got a roll there.
Dixon weed before they fucking pornos.
You can smoke the Dick.
You got to smoke your own Dick Wolf
Blitzer looks like Colonel Sanders.
I like a funeral because
he's wearing the darker suit.
Like if you went for a week,
like if the Birkin guy died
and just out of respect,
he fucking showed up.
That would be like the Sudi v wearing,
but he's got like the fucking,
the white shit going.
You guys could see this laptop.
You know that I was fucking dead on point.
Good point.
Have you ever heard this?
Found yourself having that
guilty moment where you go,
hey,
Trump's right,
we're good
to 68 Clinton.
What the fuck can't be this close?
Donald Trump definitely as a boma
to 69 to 68 you need to 70 to win.
Get the fuck Outta here.
69 that's what it says.
It can't be real.
What is Rhode Island left?
That doesn't make any sense.
That can't be a real score.
Remember when we thought
this is going to be a joke?
Oh Alaska.
Save us
both to Alaska.
My apologies.
The chill coot,
Charlies and all those for trappers up
there and everybody running from the law.
Holy Shit.
Sam,
triple your thoughts.
I'm blown away by this.
How retarded we are.
Huh?
Thanks.
[inaudible] this is I can I would
you gotta be red state by State?
What's a bigger uh,
buster Douglas.
Mike Tyson.
Donald Trump said,
ever one Florida was in Vegas for 29.
How do you fuck you?
You fucking morons in
Florida have 29 electoral
folks.
This is when I go again.
I like Miami.
I liked Miami.
Tampa dude.
Get the fuck the pauper.
Ybor city through the upper three quarters
back of that fucking pickup truck.
He boards cause I think Florida's
any more fucked up than other states.
They just don't get the shit cause
they've got a couple of water parks and
Disneyland and everybody
gets all fucking desal.
Yeah.
This is a what?
An amazing place.
More fucked up than other
state of Florida people here.
Evidently.
No,
Florida is more fucked up.
Oh wait,
now
two 61 97.
I don't know what the fuck this shown is.
Sorry guys.
Sorry.
I know I got y'all excite.
Hey,
hold it up.
Yeah,
that was Nacodoches credibility.
What's left?
There's pills.
There's,
there's getting a vein in the bathtub.
They should've started,
dude.
Hillary should have ran.
If they build a wall,
that means no cocaine.
I bet you everybody would have
voted for Hillary Clinton,
ma'am.
You said no more blow insane dude.
This is the one that I'm speaking of.
Blow.
I ran fucking Manson Outta here by trying
to get them on stage and he's a grown
man,
but we have Adderall
six feet away from you.
No,
no.
He doesn't want to go on stage.
I don't care how much coke do you know?
You don't call me if you're
six feet away from me.
An important,
this is not like a structured thing is no.
Pas here
said,
listen,
the guy pulled me out of the bad
spot today and I was at Dick,
but yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
He's still here.
He's a weird dude.
That's all right man.
I was supposed to tell you people that
this show goes on for a long fucking
time,
so
there is no structure.
It's just going to get weirder.
I'm on autopilot with the
fakest smile you'll ever see.
So if you have to Piss,
get drink,
smoke a cigarette,
beat your kids,
go take care of Jim
Jefferies kid in the car.
Whatever you have to do,
just come in and out.
We're going to have
comics coming in and out.
So yeah,
the,
okay.
Now back to the show.
Brendan Walsh,
Florida.
It is weirder.
Is that it's not weird.
Yes it is.
They'll police man.
It cooks their brains.
I tried to take a shit
in a hot tub in Florida.
Saint Motel stopped you,
Shelley.
Shelley made me stop.
I almost took Shelley's zero off with
a banana too and I was talking to my
banana phone and Shaylee was like,
hey Yo,
like threw it at him.
Fucking whipped past his ear.
He,
Brendan Walsh,
his the bed.
Oh right.
Standing up
pictures.
Oh that ain't shit.
Third Berg Quisha pissed on his
father in law's kitchen table.
So drunk
that he was in the toilet
is so great.
Hey,
that shit happens.
Okay.
Not only on their dining room table,
but when he caught me,
I,
David blamed it.
David played it and I laid under the
table cloth in my pissed and went
back to sleep.
That's what's up
and he's wearing flip flops.
I told that story,
Bro.
Man,
I don't lecture.
Yeah,
feet does have jeans and flip flops.
Why not fucking socks match my outfit.
Weed's legal now I'm happy.
You're a pioneer.
You're a pioneer in footwear.
I left my fanny pack in the car.
I was too high before I got.
Jesus is not the time.
It's not the time for the fanny pack.
It's going to get in the way.
Fanny pack.
I'll tell I'm going to tell a story.
We're fucking,
you know.
I knew when you said I
can't tell this story.
You were going to tell it.
Just tell.
I have to tell a story.
Shit's bad at home.
But when the EMT or taken
her my girlfriend out,
you got to tell the story because
my girlfriend had his seizure,
fell back,
fractured her skull.
She's still not responsive to see my ex
girlfriend cry if my ex girlfriend used
to have seizures like that all the time.
Well,
I know.
Good.
It kept burning late dinner.
Oh man,
went for it.
Y'All know where you're going with this.
You guys don't hang around
with you're fucked comedians.
Your life sucks.
That's why you paid money to be here.
That's the only way I get through life
is cause I have the best fucking comic
friends that can bust my balls.
So.
So bingo.
I know it's cocaine related.
It's her 40th birthday.
The whole family is there in Biz B.
She has a seizure fractures or skull.
They're taking her out,
the mts there holding her head.
I'm just just puking busting balls.
Crack a joke.
Joke,
joke.
Oh the pool of blood is getting bigger.
I go,
don't clean that up.
I need a good picture in daylight.
And then my dog start
licking up the blood.
So cleaning up line,
but it hovered it cause I needed
to get a picture cause it was this,
this is not the first time it's happened.
So I don't really think it's
going to end up like it is now.
Fuck her.
She knows better than to do that much PLO.
So I'm cracking wise.
I don't even know if I remember my story.
Yeah.
What was I going to not tell?
Oh the fanny pack.
So here's what happens.
The sisters,
Bingo,
sister Bongo and Bengo I call them.
They're like go,
who knows what to do?
I go,
someone go down with everyone's calling
nine one one go down and make sure
there's no coke residue or wherever.
I know she's doing coke and
then I see her fanny pack,
which he's very attached to.
She's trying to bring the fanny back.
It's not working.
But I go,
Hey,
uh,
take her fanny pack.
Cause when she wakes up
she's going to freak out.
Where's my fanny pack?
It's a mental thing and they
wouldn't have blow in there.
I go,
she's not that dumb.
Oh yes she are
the sisters.
Clean Cut.
All American sisters go to the Er.
I'm like fucking,
I'm the host of the party
now you go to the Er,
they find the blow and it's a shitload
of Blo Manson would have stayed.
So the sister smuggles it
is the eight blocks away,
but smuggles it like locked up abroad.
Hello?
I was trying to find her insurance
and I,
Holy Shit.
And then
we started doing her blow.
Stay awake,
find out the condition.
She said she knows better than to do this.
She has a problem with this.
Anyone called yet
family that's snorts
together stays together.
Did I make this weird?
Is that the national?
His podcast.
Awesome.
Still to six six to 16 two oh nine Trump.
Yeah.
That's updated.
We fucking good people
still moving on the screen,
buddy.
Within two points.
I thought that was a
projection or something.
Well,
what is it?
What is it?
I don't know if anybody knows any.
She's 32 to two oh nine it says
two 32 to two oh nine yeah.
Whoa.
He's wolf was,
she was,
you have to get to Mr.
Trump if you're listening.
I always thought you
were super fucking cool.
I love the apprentice.
I think your fucking wife is great.
Your kids are awesome.
I wasn't one of the Comedians
tweeting against you for the past.
Hey,
I'm breaking news.
Check this out.
This is true.
Here we go.
This Canadian immigration
website crashes during American,
Huh?
Holy Shit.
That's awesome.
A
bit of an overreaction,
like is it really,
no matter who wins,
it's like,
ah,
this doesn't work.
There's a couple of Canada.
Have you guys been to Canada?
I know Michael More hyped it up.
Okay.
I know we hyped it up like nobody hates
anybody and there's no racism up there.
They human beings,
they're incredibly just like us.
So if you wanted a little
colder to great place to go,
but other than that,
that just like us,
the coaches are smart,
justice,
dumb.
God bless them.
It's not a solution,
man.
Come on.
You're going to go up
there and watched the CFL.
The Fuck Outta here.
I was trying to talk to you earlier when
you were fucking with Rogan about the
conspiracy theories because a
million years ago it was Viet VHS.
Rogan was showing a no,
we faked the moon landing.
You get a watch.
This double VA
totally was.
Behold a pale horse.
You're being lied to.
I never
came from,
what are you thinking?
Oh No,
I don't blame my own
later in years,
but it was him.
That was the first conspiracy guy about
the moon landing and he's [inaudible]
grow as he is now.
So you just shut up and you watch
four hours of VHS and you go,
oh fuck yeah.
It sounds like it was faked.
And then you can go now Google is brand
new and you go debunk and he's here all
the shit that why that was wrong.
And then you go,
I don't care if we ever landed on them.
My question,
why does it Nasa just take a picture of
the car that they left up there and be
like,
boom,
drop the mic.
It's over.
They take them,
get them started.
Well then there you go.
Why does it the government,
you know a video of that
plane hitting the Pentagon.
Oh,
it's a lot of cameras on the place.
Let's just show them where this took
a big left turn that's took a big left
turn.
I went safe fucker with the mood
that gets people rational.
Bill had the fucking ball over the goal
line yesterday was Sunday whenever,
I don't know what data is and
they should have beat the chiefs.
So the,
yeah.
Jaguars was you in the Jags
[inaudible] Jackson Jaguars pan?
No,
I was just watching acted like who cared?
Another fucking dude messed up his
knees and he laid on the fucking ground,
the train.
It came out and they had
to take him out for a play.
I enjoyed that cause he wasn't fucking
way he was rolling around in the theater.
Now it has a smell.
This the field goal kicker for
the buffalo bills chairman.
The Way Carpenter was rolling
around and laying on the ground.
He thought he was really fucking hurt.
Then all of a sudden he
lines up for 50 yard field.
Would the fucking do was fine.
He was fine.
That game was a push.
Anybody betting at home?
I bet on the fucking bills plus thick.
Hey.
Oh I want sponsorship from bed online.
Dot.
Agee.
Yeah,
me too.
Do,
this might be an question.
How close are we now?
I just did you,
do you ever do line and then
I'll ask the guy in the,
he was,
we're going to have people are moving.
There's moves there.
Looks Kinda happy.
Is that Wolf Blitzer?
Cause it's not.
It's,
it's another white guy
was salt and pepper hair.
I know.
I liked that guy.
I don't,
not Anderson Cooper.
He's a giant gala.
We've legalized weed.
What's the next,
what's,
what's the next level drug?
You go to the dressing and the about
cigarettes texting in the back.
I could see you.
Your face is lit up like it.
Tell him to go story.
Go ahead.
I love Texas in the dark.
He was a dark and stormy night.
We were at the comedy store.
It's allegedly haunted.
You see this is all just
fucking backlash for the cubs.
You know,
if the cubs lost troubled a lot.
Ah,
that goes to the hubs
is it doesn't matter.
It will make it a fucking come back.
Woo Doug.
It Trussell just kind of get a look guilty
duck.
When they took the fucking general lead
and they took that rebel flag off the
top of that bitch.
That's what people had.
Enough brought up nation,
a lot of red on that map.
That and Caitlyn Jenner,
there's a storm.
A Duncan Trussell just texted me,
make America great again.
He couldn't be here in person.
Him,
man to man.
Fuck it.
Hey,
is anyone in the shoot?
Dude,
Trump won.
Trump is one 23 states.
He could still lose the election.
Tell you what.
I was in big Tony Soprano fan.
I knew he was a murderer.
I love that dude.
I was looking at,
come on Tony.
Pull herself together at your best.
You're really cool guy.
She's one,
one,
two,
three,
four,
five,
six,
seven,
eight
to that kid wouldn't shut the fuck up.
Huh?
Eight states to 23 and he's only
up by like fucking 10 points.
I can't wrap my head around
this fucking election stuff.
Did a lot of great shit.
Plus he was a rapist.
Maybe got a separate,
you gotta separate the two.
Donald Trump could pull it together.
It'll be like what a man
does on his own time.
Yes is no reflection of
his artistic contributions.
This man made a great cartoon,
a single camera shoot and sitcoms.
He ran the home.
They're laughing and crying and cut.
That's another story for the people
that are only engaging in audio brick
Christ.
Everyone laughs
and all I saw was plumber,
plumber crack her.
It says the fucking amazing
make chicken strips great again.
What is he eating?
America is going to be great again.
We're going to go back to horse rides
and we're gonna make our own food because
there'll be no more grid after the war.
We kind of pieced it
together as good as we could.
It turns out all the smart people.
Dot first
maybe this is just a Nathan for you bit.
We're going to make it back
into the fucking,
uh,
CNN.
We're all going to be
fly fishing for dinner.
We're going to be skinny as fuck like
people from the civil war days and the
average dude weighed 125
pounds during the civil war.
How about them apples?
Wait,
are we going to be cooking
venison on a freeway?
Cause any
tiny Monte people that can barely get
by mountain lions running through the
streets.
Is that what you want,
by the way?
Do the elk spend?
Delicious.
Thank you.
No,
you like it.
I made this American chopped suey with
it and my wife gave a fucking bad review
before anybody even tasted
it and everybody just said,
fuck it like that.
She goes,
it looks like hamburger helper.
I've been showering it for like four days.
Like I had a respect for that
fucking health that you shot.
It's like I'm eating all this shit.
I don't care if it's fucking bed.
Does it make you more aggressive?
What?
No,
no,
Joe,
you're fucking loaded.
Tick.
Okay.
Somebody gets in my face.
That might cause me to get more lunatic.
Ate a little bit of protein.
You had to beat the fuck out of people
for like three decades before you could
like chill,
smoke a little weed,
put on your little rascals hat.
It's fucking chill.
I love him to death.
This guy is the most testosterone
fucking fill dude I've ever met.
That's why I love him.
I love him.
He's like every guy in men
Boston fucking welded together.
He's crazy.
Will haunt me for the rest of my,
no,
no.
Put this on Russian.
He's crushing that hat.
Come on.
You know where he is.
You're killing it.
I love it.
You don't have to balance it out.
I like it.
I'm laughing at me too.
I'll never put this thing on again.
No,
you shut up dude.
I'm going to stick it in the fireplace.
You shouldn't know
you're killing it though.
We'll keep it on for when the
papers come out in the morning.
Extra extra.
Read all about it.
Charlie.
Finally,
Bill's a fucking bed.
This is,
what do we do now,
folks?
Have you ever had someone like make fun
of you to a point where it affected the
rest of your life?
Teresa Neal.
Every fucking two days when you saw
these feel best friend named Tom Segura,
when Patrice passed away.
Ah,
Tommy,
Tommy.
When Patrice died,
I didn't know him well,
but there was part of me that went.
It was isis is no longer a threat
because he was so terrifying.
I never got on his badge
on the funniest I ever met,
but I was so scared.
I'll tell you how bad he gets this close.
He turned the biggest loud mouth comedians
into fucking audience members and he
would be out on the street.
I'm selling one night he fucked with
some transvestite and they went back and
forth giving each other shit.
It was fucking,
she got a good one and she said to him,
she goes,
you got so many spaces between your teeth,
it looks like your tongue's in jail.
We were all fucking flipping
out and it's a thing.
He started on the panel,
weathered that storm.
He laid on the ropes.
Like Ali knew that she just had stopped
jokes cause he looked at me and he shook
it off going,
that's just fucking stock shit.
Like he had heard it,
but I was so white.
I was like,
Ooh,
that's brand new to me.
That's hilarious.
And he sees this light
manner than a thousand times.
And when she ran out of the shit,
dude,
he fucking destroyed her
and she had a walk off man.
It was fucking,
it was,
it was.
It was unreal.
Dude.
I'm as literally as Jeff Ross,
me,
David,
tell Bobby Kelly some of the
biggest fucking comics ever.
We just sat there and watched it with one.
If you ever see,
you ever see that?
That that,
that biggie video of went before he
was famous when he was freestyle and he
trashed that dude stooped.
It was the comedy version of that dude.
No,
not even exaggerating.
It was fucking unbelievable.
Go ahead.
All right,
well first of all,
you have a story about some time,
but that's another who's the
scariest comic is a good question,
but tell your story about when you get
insulted that it stayed with you for
life.
You jumped up.
You're going to get a story.
I get a,
I'm to opt out of this voting.
All right then I'm bringing in Hay.
We need some,
we need some beaver in here.
Ellen Earth Kerrigan.
Fucking take over for me.
I need a cigarette.
I need to flush my own head
down a toilet Kerrigan.
No,
you're right here.
You're taking my spot.
You're right here.
I'll hold it.
Oh Shit.
What's up?
My little friend
plus hilarious comedian plus
waitress at the comedy store.
Who needs it?
No,
Eleanor.
When?
When I first started working here,
I would always go to her when,
when new people would come into town,
if I hadn't seen him,
I go,
I heard that guy's really funny.
She would go,
she would let me know.
It's true.
What's a matter of right?
Because this thing keeps
freezing on key shit.
Oh Shit.
This laptop that doesn't have
a fucking mouse or anything,
you can click on.
It's like watching porn and
it freezes on the dude's face.
Yeah.
Oh my God.
This is,
yeah.
This is a fucking now,
but are you scared?
A little bit.
What are you scared about most?
Ah,
you grabbing pussy grabbing.
That's fine with me.
Uh,
I prefer that more of an Ain as grabber.
Oh,
thanks.
Got that wrestling background.
You don't have to describe it.
They're going to ping you.
You're just give me all fucking fish.
Fish,
hook,
reach around fishing.
Fucking coolest.
There's in the business.
I'm not doing bleeding.
Nevada.
She's leading Pennsylvania.
I'll thank God,
dude.
This is coming down to the fucking why.
Yeah.
How do
you
know what your religion,
no vaginal stick it in her ass.
He's fucking,
he's killing it.
Hillary is 52 to 21 and
some other mother fuckers.
Maybe that was just a county.
I get excited.
I get excited about things.
I see numbers and I flipped by
great commentating on Al Capone's vault.
You guys like 10 times and I apologize.
I'm trying to do my best.
I'm going to go with this.
I'm not cool with this technology shit.
We're about to open it up.
Nothing.
All right.
Michigan,
New Hampshire,
Pennsylvania,
Wisconsin.
Too early to call.
As much as I've been
fucking you guys over.
If you really gave a shit,
you wouldn't be here.
How do you think like
fucking do caucus there?
Walter Mondale feels
got blown out.
Gary Hart.
Yeah,
exactly.
She sucked my Dick.
Go Fuck Yourself.
It was great on the bow.
Anyway.
I don't,
I don't know if I'm scared though.
Joe,
like you said,
you said,
what am I scared of?
I mean maybe just just the Donald
Trump is such a fucking loose cannon,
but that could work for us.
No
comments.
Oh,
I see.
Comedy wise.
I like glass
ineffective way to run a bunch of
people that you don't even know.
True.
Hey,
I'm looking to fucking buy a house.
Maybe prices will fucking go down.
What's everybody leaves the fucking day.
So that's a bright side.
Once we'll be able to afford
a house in silver lake.
All right,
this say in two 32 Trump two oh nine clin.
Now one motherfucker two third tie.
Dye harder.
You gotta give him a respect
diehard in the corner.
Come on.
Trump supporter in Hollywood.
I got love that I got to 38 Trump Adderall
fucked that bitch.
Oh Dude is nine o'clock Pacific time.
New Hampshire is still too close to call.
It's fucking crazy.
It's midnight out there.
Only 13 people up there.
Fuck.
Are they talking about
the what the fuck?
Nah.
Who has the answers?
Kyle country.
That's God's country.
It's fucking beautiful.
Vermont.
All those trees and people are addicted
to heroin back out there and the
florist.
Do we have a lot of Trump supporters?
I'm kidding.
It's frozen again.
This fucking thing.
You got to bring it down.
Okay,
so then you bring it back up.
I don't think he's shy.
Did I?
Lost it?
Some magnet.
Bill Baer.
Worst Ipod,
shitty juggler ever brought
it down at broad peck up.
That works at home.
Dean del Rey.
Where's the bill burr?
Is Anybody?
I don't know.
Jamie.
Ridiculous.
One old.
That's where it's going.
This is the closest I'll ever
beat it being my Goldberg.
You're correct Joe.
They what they need to do is posture up
right now with the IPAC.
You're absolutely
correct and we didn't pay
bearing round trying to fix the
IPAD and they are in big trouble.
Bulk of up reputations on the line.
They don't know how to bend up the thing
to this fucking thing.
They threw the iPad back.
Let's just go with the pat.
Kevin Durant is all golden state.
Are you buying or selling?
That's what you get
with your non committal.
That fucking piece of shit
is neither a keyboard.
And if you are both,
you do not exist.
Yes.
This represents the transgender
bathrooms that we lead in this
fuck
that represents 71 at
Santa decried on the fence.
No fairness.
Oh,
thank you.
We could still use your health.
How do you make it stand up?
You don't.
You hold it like a man.
I got it.
Dean,
Dean del Rey.
Stop.
You guys should choose
fucking stupid for that thing.
That doesn't make any sense.
Does that make sense?
Does it no flipping around.
Oh Shit.
Trump won.
Oh kidding.
Oh the air got sucked of the room
mixed up when I had mother
fucker in the corner.
I got you.
Huh?
Bill Baer.
Ladies and gentlemen.
Huh?
Gimme that shit bitch.
You guys on a Caltrans.
God Damn my pad.
If you let it fly away,
put the mic.
Stand behind it.
Any other document in front of you?
Don't do it to
kill the mic.
Stand helper.
There were some who feels
like they're invested in this.
Did people feel invested in this?
But Dude,
I'm a job.
This is like one of the great
games I've ever watched.
Some sports.
This is fucking incredible.
Two 32 two oh nine with
fucking 10 minutes to go.
Donald Trump kicking
off the Hillary Clinton.
Can I ask you?
You Take it,
Huh?
That's true.
What's your favorite rep before today?
Shoes.
Wow.
You could have gotten,
if you went to Vegas,
you bet a buck.
You would've won $10 everybody.
He'll go on and Mcdonald's gets
you 10 of those dollar meals.
I walked down the street with the
little burger king hat on Mcdonald's,
Burger King or whatever you want to win.
I am such a cunt that
when Hillary's winning,
I want Trump to win.
Well,
Trump is winning
because I live in La.
I like saying Trump shit
just to annoy people.
But if I lived in Kentucky,
I would be gone.
I would be going like Hillary,
man.
I would just,
I just like annoying people.
That's what it really comes down to.
Like,
you know,
as much as people think I'm a misogynist,
I agree with 90% of the shit feminists
say until it comes out of a woman's mouth
arguing,
dare you,
because that's who I am.
That's who I am and I understand that
and I don't try to steer away from it.
The machine per Chrysler show.
Friday night,
10:00 PM 11,
right?
10:00 PM on showtime.
It's called the machine.
What did you live in the mountains?
What could he get?
11:00 PM 11.
Uh,
I asked him,
I said,
why don't we go to 11 1111?
Well you want to lose a million viewers
and we can do that or we can do it at
10:00 PM and I was like,
oh,
let's do it at 10:00 PM
that's good.
Where are we at bill?
Uh,
we're at two 32 two oh nine Donald Trump.
But there's still some sandals to 38
update too is better than connected to the
keyboard.
Yeah.
Two 44 two who's who's the Trump?
Oh Two oh nine.
Oh my God.
A reality TV show star is pulling ahead.
Only the wife of a president.
You know,
he should have chose Dat
Phan as his running mate,
but you're ready to pick up on it.
The only thing good about
MILF porn is going to take off.
Like first lady porn is just
going to skyrocket your point.
First Lady Porn.
Hey,
we'll be starting the actual Hillary wins.
And bill gets back into the
like sort of the office,
but he doesn't have the responsibility
having to take calls and all of that
shit.
Like how much pussy is
this guy going to get?
Like this is what's amazing about Hillary.
She did the exact same thing Al Gore did
was she just completely shut that guy
out of his,
out of a fucking campaign
because he's such a,
you know,
you start sticking cigars
and you know people's twats.
I mean people got to take a step back.
I think will's going to play it straight
up all first ladies going to do the
dishes,
you know what I mean?
Just a little laundry,
shit like that.
Somebody still,
somebody called it the
first gentleman today.
Did you see that?
The guys the furthest from a gentleman,
you know what I love about him?
I'm not judging him,
but when Trump called him off
for being a pussy hound too,
and he had the fucking balls
to sit there with that,
that fucking angry look on his face,
he should've just been like,
hey,
you got me.
You got it.
I love it.
I Love Hillary.
But
love Pussy.
I Love Hillary enough
to stay with their by.
You know the fucking,
if you know that,
that Sweet Paula Jones Pussy
with round walls,
what am I supposed to do?
I've got a nice humor door with some
of the Cubans that Kennedy bought right
before the embargo.
What am I supposed to do?
What is any person supposed
to do in that situation?
That's what I ask you as we wait for
the final decision on Pennsylvania.
It is riveting.
You're alive,
Bill.
Best in Sarasota.
How high are you right now?
I heads he took one hit.
It's this Jamison.
Give credit where credit is due.
I think it's both.
No,
no,
no.
You weed.
Guys always want to take
credit for fucking this.
Hey Man.
Where'd that thinking come from,
Jamison.
All right.
I'm a big fan of alcohol.
I agree.
You spend time.
Hey Joe.
You know what?
I'm a big fan of you and
that's the pot speaking,
right?
By the way,
that is a moment that
we'll lose podcast ever.
I'm am such a good thing.
Should be on MSNBC.
This is fucking how the
news should have delivered.
Let's just say one thing.
It is Donald Trump projected to
when I was six electoral votes
dead.
No shafted.
I loved Iowa,
but they loved guns.
They're like,
listen bitch,
we got important decisions to make.
Number one is we live in the
middle of fucking nowhere.
We need guns.
It's
38 two oh nine
Trump iPhone,
iPhone two 34 on t
mobile bitch to 44 yeah,
fine bro.
I know we're running out
of San Diego state here.
This doesn't look good,
man.
Two 44 where's Waldo says
it's two 44 over here.
What are you going,
you got that new sprint.
Is that what you got to say?
That I've always been for Trump and I'm
really excited about Trump and we need
and when he looks back and watches this
big podcasts that happened that I was
always for you Donald L.
Dot.
Cleansing.
I'm going to be one of your top spokesman
claiming it now that have all these
guys and they're all
making jokes against you.
I was on your slide body,
Tony Hinch stuffs like
the Nazi and the strain.
I just want,
I just want to stay,
whatever the fuck this guy's doing.
People are going to move
to Canada and Mexico,
but he's about to new there.
So that shit though.
I mean he's hitting the
red button like a fucking,
I don't know what Benjamin buttons.
It's all gonna be fine.
Everybody fuck way out.
We're all cool.
We're good.
Well,
he's going to quit in two years.
The I fucked this job.
It's going to be the first guy will
be great and then it's vice president.
I'll be like,
you asshole
dude.
He'll quit over Twitter.
Yeah.
All you gotta do is just
keep giving him shit.
You won't even pay attention
to the foreign policy.
You'd be too busy tweeting
at fucking John Stewart.
Here's my new prediction.
In the next three months,
Donald Trump sells the white house.
Yeah.
Just the fucking crazy billionaire.
Who Isa Fuck I say he,
he loads his name to it.
What?
That White House?
Yeah.
He puts his name on it.
Like those shitty house.
Hi,
are you living in a shitty reality show?
He's actually going to shoot
his new show in the White House.
Secretary of state apprentice style.
Exactly.
Good foreign policy.
Moroso you get Pennsylvania
now we're waiting.
This is,
this is the thing.
I was huge.
Clinton is at 48.2%
to 45% she needs to shit.
If Trump takes,
this dude is fucking
like Michael Corleone.
Godfather to
a lot of Catholics in Pennsylvania.
Yeah.
Lot of Catholics in Pennsylvania.
That's Trump territory right there.
What's crazy is that people in other
countries are watching this 50 50 race.
Then they're watching it happen just
like we are and they're all like,
oh,
not so United after all
because we do it like many states,
like fucking idiots.
That should just be straight
up popular vote bitches.
It's split up.
The map is redder than his face right now.
Look at that.
It's just the all red.
I got a question.
Is it about time that we dissolve dates?
Yeah.
Why isn't it when
you,
when you take Pi entering
Colorado come a criminal,
why do we need states?
States are like
this glorified boundaries
in between lines of dirt.
We arbitrarily draw and decide,
well,
we're used to ride with feathers.
They just thought this was Wyoming.
I can't go there with my fucking gay
porn and people would get mad at me.
Throw me in a fucking prison.
That's ridiculous,
right?
It is ridiculous,
but it's great.
It's a great feeling up.
Your progress as you
drive across the country.
America,
you need them really good point markers.
We retained the name and
we just abandoned the idea.
We can't all decide collectively
without electoral colleges,
without senators and representative.
We don't need representatives.
We don't ride horses.
We have
dare you pull me.
I'm
talking off the top of my head.
Barely know what the fuck I'm saying.
Hey,
when are you going to
take a guy at the bar?
The button.
I don't even know you bro.
When are you going to take
me a wild boar hunting?
I want to go to that.
We're going to do it in this,
Greg.
Well,
what?
We're going to do a control.
Fucking blow his brains out.
I don't like the noise.
They make a difficult shot.
What about this job?
What if we divvy it up into
50 different countries?
No,
no.
The United States.
You don't want to do that.
A designer.
Why would you do that?
Cause then you'd stay away
from certain countries,
but you're all be vulnerable.
They can pick you off where we can all
fucking go to war and he's 50 dude,
that's a don't,
don't give Trump any ideas.
Does that for me?
Oh,
problem is then listen.
Good.
The problem with that is that
Texas run the fucking country.
If we,
if we had a war of the countries,
take a hit off tigers,
they have nuclear weapons.
But if you're a Germaphobe,
I heard your herpes bit
[inaudible] I got a
great herpes story.
Went rogue it buddy
my first.
I have the good herpes on my Dick.
Oh,
has the unfortunate lip Herbie here.
And again I come back,
Dan Sores,
cold sores on your morals.
They don't go,
Ooh,
is it chilly where you're
from and your Dick,
so Rogan,
this is,
I can just thank you dean.
Thanks so Rogan.
We're doing the man show.
This is before.
I've just like once I said I have herpes,
almost every one of my friends he goes,
oh fuck I have herpes too
because we fucked.
They say like one out of five
that's including everybody
like your grandparents.
So if you're fucking,
it's like one out of two.
So Rogan gets a cold sore on his
lip and I had just gotten val trex
and we have to film the next day's a fuck.
I wish I had Valtrex cause I'm
getting a cold sore and I had it,
but I didn't want to
admit that I had heard.
So I made him tape with a lot of
gunky makeup on his fucking face.
Sorry Joe.
How dare you Doug.
Hey Bill.
Do you mind if I drink with my cock?
No.
Why don't,
why don't you just pour it into
a glass like a goddamn gentleman
charts.
I don't know what happened,
but I was a little baby
when I realized it.
I'd get these little sores on my lip
and I knew that one day one of my best
friends would shame me for these stores,
these stores that I had no all over.
I was born with these tours.
I had him since I was a tiny little boy.
Nervous and scared,
low back
future.
But this guy getting coked up and bang
and hookers fucking driving on Greyhound
buses across the country.
Fucking everybody in the ass.
This guy got herpes to maybe
different kinds of herpes.
What do you think?
Huh?
Maybe the little baby.
The little kid should have got to decide
whether or not like I woke up one day.
I had cold sores.
I didn't fuck anybody.
Cold Sores.
No coke,
no Adderall,
no mushrooms,
no bad decisions.
That's so boring.
The fuck is this.
Fuck this Doug.
Stan hope.
One of my best friends
sit on my lap.
Geez Joe.
You don't have to be such a sore loser.
No,
Doug,
for a long time,
if you starts to shake it off his legs,
he's got,
he's going to not tell
you that he's injured.
Not Good.
You're gonna choke his legs out.
Anyway,
Tony,
give us your thoughts on the war.
Uh,
you mean though?
What does the civil war to
starting tomorrow out in reality,
tomorrow's civil war to
the battle of America.
This sequel.
You never thought you'd see again,
Huh?
No,
I'm just watching this.
They're projecting all these states.
Oh my God.
Trump 40 Pennsylvania's 48.2 to 48.22%
of the vote is in and they just did like
four other states and they will
project and Trump winning those what?
Nevada mo to Hillary's up
49.3 44.8 Hillary Clinton.
Okay.
Minnesota 48.9 to 48.3 yeah.
Hillary Clinton.
The tensions.
Kellen Ya,
what's the total dose?
I'm going to just whatever.
That guy in the corner said
he's got the feet for Chrysler.
What's up?
Oh,
I should be noted that yesterday my dad
pulled all of his money out of the stock
market and right now the stock market
has halted because it's dropped so low.
No,
it's supposed to already be closed.
How?
How was it halted,
Bill?
You don't know when they're
going to listen to this.
Asian markets.
It's Asia markets.
I know a lot of stuff they'll stop by.
Bad guys just said in the audience.
Sunset Strip come in the same score
off at one day.
Do you realize the fucking people when
when like someone gets elected or not get
selected,
the people that move that money,
it's not guys like you or me.
They always go like
stockholders freaked out.
It's no,
it's a fucking Bilderberg cunts that can,
that can pull the whole thing up.
Oh yeah.
Cause I saw it on a website.
Okay.
Michigan,
New Hampshire,
Pennsylvania,
Wisconsin.
Still too early to call too early to call.
It's not comb over til the fat lady sings.
You know who had the best take on that?
I just thought of it right then.
Don't look at me like that bill.
He'll do better.
We need to look what you
didn't know what's going on.
Tony,
I loved you until that moment.
Neil degrasse Tyson,
Arizona,
Utah,
Nevada,
Minnesota,
Wisconsin.
Get your fucking head on [inaudible],
Michigan.
Those are all mustard.
How drunk Pennsylvania to it and be like
nine of these things were Hampshire,
Michigan.
It was no secret we were going to
come out here and get fucked up.
That was the mission of this.
No secret Uber.
It's no reason to pry.
I'm fucking walk.
I'm staying down the street.
I'm walking
occasionally I'll fucking,
I'll roll the dice.
You know I've been there.
You get in there,
you want a little excitement in your life.
How about everything I ever worked
for gets pushed onto the table.
What happens?
Ah,
fuck are the people's loved ones.
I want a Taco.
It's like the shit.
Your pants of life.
He's just fucking rolling.
Be with me on this.
When you listen to someone just
to hear what you want them to say.
The podcast you did with bird.
Oh,
there's the three hours.
Yeah,
and Segura and at some
point he'll Burchette.
You know what?
Fuck it.
I'm drinking for the rest of my life.
I need a heater.
But I remember old podcast where you go,
yeah,
I'm not going to drank for like 43 days.
Just good for your liver.
I'm still sober.
And I'm like,
Ooh,
that's bad.
He said that on your podcast.
He goes,
fuck it.
I'm dragging it forever.
I'm going to drink till I die.
Fuck it.
I go,
I'm never listening to bill burr again.
Cause I heard what I want to hear.
My,
I have nothing to do for
the rest of the night.
I am walkable distance away from my bed.
There's no reason to be sober.
That's why I drink on the road
the best part of the podcast,
the very end we've done,
we've only got a three hour podcasts,
totally sober and bill goes,
I could use a heater and so girl goes,
what?
And he goes,
come to make the drive interesting home.
Gotcha.
When I learned what a heater was and I
had a corner room in the green room last
week and go,
hey the heater,
I thought that was a
cigar but that's a shot.
I was a fucking complete fanboy.
Listened to your podcast,
poked you a chill coot Charlie's
put a heater.
Is that a thing or a thing?
Oh,
what's a heater?
One of my all time favorite people.
Tell me about that really drives me crazy.
You somehow or another this
guy like a filter for love.
Like he,
he like denies it.
He gets his point where he just does it.
Like it keeps him honest as a comic.
He wants to pretend that people don't
love and we'll people love the fuck out of
them.
Every now and then we
got to go with all dude.
Ah,
he's one of my,
one of my favorite all time too.
Comedians
and I'm just so lucky they
cabin you guys as friends.
Tony Hedge live Berg kind of Eleanor.
I love the fuck out of you.
All right,
Dean del Ray.
I love the fuck out of you.
One of my favorites to sit
on all of this hat.
He's crying,
he's crying.
No one's hugging him right now.
Super Cool.
I love that dude.
I know
he's at a Donald Trump route.
Every one of these,
every one of these states,
it's,
I'm telling you to do what it's say.
It's within like fucking 2000 votes.
I'm crazy.
I'm going to start a new show
on CBS to Michigan's mushrooms.
1.7 4 million births,
1.71 9 million.
We're going to start with
the yoga class was constant.
1.2 verse 1.1
shoot.
I'm going to get it wrong.
This is fucking meditate.
This one show one quick show.
Donald.
No big deal.
12 episodes round.
Six episodes in.
Hold on.
Doug's pulling the Burt right now.
Joe.
Great chicken tenders.
I really,
oh,
oh.
Once people have some fucking vegetables.
Oh shit
ways.
Gentlemen,
let's take your mind.
How are you?
I'm wearing my never tap out shirt.
Super important with Hillary and
Ruth Bader Ginsburg and flotus on it.
Oh Wow.
Your vote counted for nothing today.
Oh,
first lady.
first lady flotus.
Was I supposed to know that float?
That's what Trump's going to
call his haircut tomorrow.
Give me a very interesting subject group.
Lotus.
Lotus,
right?
Yeah.
Do you know what flotus and did
you immediately recognize it?
Did you know what I'm saying?
Let's do that.
You say that still wants to
engage in romantic relationships.
Flotus and potency.
This is all important.
Hello?
You recognize photos?
Yes.
Yeah,
I know.
When he comes to see,
oh,
where's the Joe Rogan's wife?
I paid for Rogan know if
you're the fucking wife.
Just that's what he's saying is it's
a weird gig to be the first lady
until Joe,
but I'm going on chill.
That's till fucking
wife of the guy matter.
Exactly.
That's that Michelle Obama for president.
Fuck it.
Are you saying he's saying the president?
Oh,
they know.
Why isn't the president
never heard either one of their policies?
Just what color is their blouse?
Are you saying that the wife of
the president of the United States?
Doesn't matter.
I'm saying that Michelle Obama,
the current wife should run for president.
No.
Absolutely.
Why?
Because she danced Allen.
Oh,
the wife of the president versus the
actually running the country is so fucking
different fucking break
dude.
And you're out there
crushing it and arenas you.
Your husband should then
go do is fucking stand up.
Cause he hollered a notebook.
It's not different.
This whole fucking thing with these
first ladies fucking low picking a damn
cause and all of a sudden my
presidential is fucking ridiculous.
It's not ridiculous.
Ridiculous was women have an opinion
and we talk in your ear all the time.
Are you telling me that when you designed
your house it was all your decision
has nothing.
It has nothing to do with signing that
you can go onto or wherever the fuck you
want and your wife is like
what it has to do with is
actually doing the job,
doing the job.
There was a nurse I hung.
I was just like him out.
I was,
my mother was a nurse at home with
her from my whole fucking life.
Okay.
If someone came into the ICU unit,
I didn't know what the fuck to do.
Well that's because you are fucking
around with her with scrubs.
You're not trained as a nurse.
Barack Obama is a lawyer
and so is Michelle.
That's not a politician,
but it doesn't matter like he wasn't
a politician when he got elected.
That was the whole thing.
No,
no,
no.
You're talking about going from never
being a politician to the highest fucking
office ever.
Exactly what Trump is doing.
Exactly what form you fucking lunatic.
That is sexist shit right there.
I didn't say I didn't stay there.
That is the bullshit.
That is
bullshit.
I was a white knight and I was
trying to fuck Stair Tiana.
I'd be yelling at you right now.
Bill.
Burn.
It's fucking bullshit.
I'll wait till you're done.
If you do think,
oh cool.
Who is that billionaire
[inaudible] do you think
time
he took his shirt off.
We reacted to it.
Who's that fucking dope?
Who fucked up New York City?
Just cause he had $1 billion.
He was never an office.
Do you think that?
Yeah,
that fucking guy jerk off total fucking
shirt off and he's got his desk.
So there you go.
Mrs Bloom back.
Well it doesn't,
no,
I'm saying that guy,
that guy was a jerk off and he actually
transcended the state constitution and
was like,
fuck it.
I'm not.
Then being in the fucking
guy here and continued on.
That was bullshit.
And this is the thing.
If you fucking do the thing about all of
this shit is if you criticize Hillary,
it means automatically you're a sexist.
I didn't say that.
I just said that the first
lady voted for Trump.
If Hillary was really
no words in my mouth,
that's not what I said.
I'm putting what you said.
You said that someone with no experience
can't take on the highest office of the
world.
And I said,
but Trump just did that.
That's all I said.
Trump has had no experience and he's
going to take over in the orbit.
That's all I was the point I was making.
I was not saying,
I don't understand what your point is.
Why is Hillary is no different
than a reality TV show stars,
ladies.
That's like what your point.
You said the first lady right now,
Michelle Obama could never be president
because you can't go from a no
experience to running the
biggest office in the world.
I said I disagree because
that's why 100% never said that.
I,
that's what I thought
you said June 1st I mean
once you inferred.
I don't think so.
I'm,
I'm almost positive.
I just reacted to what you
said so we can rewind it,
but if you did it,
you did it.
So you have a Twitter handle.
Hold on,
hold on.
We got voted and like
she would have to run.
I never said any of that.
All I said was the first
lady has experienced
fence.
Oh good.
How long were you said was
you guys to be in dispute?
You're both.
We're not.
We're just disagreeing guys.
The point that I'm making,
if you're married to someone
not in the field that you're in,
does not make you
qualified to do that job.
That's all I just said.
If you're married to a,
to a guy who built houses
and you don't build houses,
that doesn't mean that I want to live in
something that you just fucking built.
That's all I'm saying.
You know,
you make some good points there.
Yeah.
Kind of.
You'd like to say,
oh,
Whoa,
Sarah.
Tiana would also like to speak.
Well,
I'm just saying that like,
of course you're saying that if she is
Jesse because you're married to somebody
with a job.
I feel,
I feel like,
I feel like I'm listening to somebody.
Talk about where the Cleveland Indians
were the best team in baseball last year.
I mean it's already pretty much,
no,
no.
This is where Bob Backlund was better
than red is super fly snuck up.
Wow.
No,
this is where I paid regular friends.
Everybody knows is Bob Backlund cliff.
It's a not two teams is
not team ps and team.
Vagina and he can't stay you jail.
Okay.
Yeah.
I was trying to transcend this fucking
horse shit of what is your genitalia?
This is therefore what you think.
That's all I was trying to try and set.
Okay.
Brought up a good point that we do.
If you don't know how to do the job,
why do we have democracy?
Why are we voting?
We're fucking all dumb on this panel.
No,
the paid to be here,
so not true.
Wait fucking smarter than me.
Looking at me right now.
Going all right.
I,
for one,
when I say we're totally qualified
to be talking about this,
I think we're good.
I don't know why anyone
would question the opinions.
This real quick,
Doug,
you're a victim of your own scouts.
Hey,
you're beautiful.
You are my favorite people that's
ever walked the face of the planet.
You're up there with king is Tom Neighbor,
Abraham Lincoln's,
so settle the fuck down.
Are you calling me a mud?
Race
trains
the fucking step people.
People lives in this depth
and lived in felt tense.
My point was that democracy is
flawed in that idiots can vote.
We're saying they can run to what they do.
They know what they do,
but we vote for that.
Right.
Honest question.
What's the solution?
Well,
that's dumb before I called you dumb,
dumb.
Really?
There's no way I barely
can keep putting that.
Paying attention to
what the fuck I'm doing.
I don't know what you do.
You know what I think the solution is?
We just have to wait for idiots to die
and we have to hope that like smarter
people keep getting born.
That's true.
That's why the Duggar's
need to be executed.
We're not going anywhere else there.
I just had two daughters.
You're part of the problem.
It's narrow.
Tiana
necessarily disagree with you,
but I think even those people that
just a victim of circumstance.
Shit.
Hillary won Nevada.
What were the odds on that?
Two 38 to 15 going into
the fourth quarter.
Hillary's so excited
with it had passed out.
Trump has [inaudible] ma'am.
Yeah.
There's no waiting for Pennsylvania.
They have a called Wisconsin yet,
right?
They haven't called Wisconsin.
They have,
but it's not looking at that.
We call Pennsylvania.
Here's what she asked again.
What are their options?
Is it easy?
She has to get Wisconsin.
If she gets like the
mustard colored sticks.
You know what's really scary,
Michigan?
I don't know what's going on,
dude.
I didn't know I was going to
be in front of the computer.
No,
no.
We already know that we are
a little children got older.
Yeah.
And this is what this
fucking system is based on.
Little children that got older
back when they used to ride horses.
That's so Meta.
It's real head Israel.
No,
I love it.
You're so right.
I never rode a horse
to this whole fucking thing.
Like there's a long history
of the United States.
People lived to be a hundred years.
The United States was founded
in 1776 that's three people ago.
Okay.
Three.
Pete started this fucking
thing that's kind of trippy.
Joe Rogan,
I have breaking news.
Ladies and gentlemen from
my home state of Florida,
amendment number two,
medical marijuana has passed.
Oh,
and ladies and gentlemen of Joe Rogan,
Joe Rogan is also passed in
the state of Massachusetts.
The problem with that is if
people get high in Massachusetts,
they realize,
listen,
there's a place I can go in January.
What's it's not nearly as fucking cool.
Wait,
we have more breaking news.
Hillary just announce the start
of her new reality show tomorrow.
Starts Taping tomorrow immediately.
What's the name of it?
Tony,
you quick mother fucker now
Tony Secretary of steaks.
Yeah.
Wait and also the secret service
just tweeted for the first time ever.
They just said
that's it.
That's all they said.
They just said laws.
They're in for a party.
Those guys,
it looks like the secret's out.
Somebody is tweeting.
Trumps going to be taking pictures
of the guys like in the hallway.
This guy's a creep.
We're showing ideas.
Yup.
Joey Diaz is a man of many mysteries.
You never know.
Josie Diaz.
We'll be here.
We're going to 11 motherfuckers.
It's only nine 30 right now.
Ooh,
I thought he was there cause
I saw him on periscope.
You guys know that the only reason why
you had to pay monies because Doug,
Stan hope this motherfucker.
I was like what to do with the money.
We've talked about this earlier,
talked about this.
Yes.
Ladies and Gentlemen,
Ladies and gentlemen,
Morgan Murphy,
perhaps you should be.
It could be as the main site.
We're thinking about
a charitable donation.
All the money that we're,
we're,
we're not taking money from it.
Okay,
good.
Hope I or all the guests
you would be with me.
We're not going to give this to a fucking
charity that's going to get 90% to pay
a z o and make dijour.
It's absolutely,
absolutely we have to figure
out to do with the money
and we'll go with that.
But we're not taking a dime.
No.
We'll find something weird again.
A Kona.
Keep it here.
We give it to the surplus card.
Oh my God.
Why don't you just sponsor people
who want to move from this country?
Why don't you sponsor people's
trips out of the advocate?
That's the smartest move.
Cause honestly,
when it,
the hardest thing is finding
someone to help you move.
We found one bit,
I'm sorry.
No,
it's fine.
Yeah.
There's a microphone there,
so,
and you'll get selected.
Yeah.
Okay.
We're going to pay.
Yeah.
Pay for them to leave.
Yeah,
I like that.
Yeah.
It's a really good concept.
There you go.
Right.
His money.
Where his mouth,
I dunno.
Sarah Tiana.
Do you lean right or lean left?
Do you seem like a chick with a gun?
Uh,
no.
No.
I'm terrified of guns.
I am.
Yeah.
Yeah,
yeah.
I don't understand.
Like my brother in law has a
bunch of them and I'm always like,
why do you need them?
He's like,
I'll go to protect this house.
I'm like,
but nobody wants her DVD player.
You know what I mean?
Like,
I don't know.
I don't understand,
but I also don't understand,
like I don't mind the shotgun because my
dad had a shotgun when we growing up we
ate the food.
He killed that one time,
you know?
So it was fun.
But I don't like semiautomatic weapons.
I think they're weird.
There should be limitations
on how symptoms.
Yeah,
because I feel like,
don't you feel like the same person that
buzzes semiautomatic weapon is the same
person that buys a Ferrari jacket?
It's a fair,
it's a fair question.
Like you're like,
I don't know.
That seems excessive in early man.
When I was listening to
that on Netflix and I go,
I dunno.
I Dunno what this,
I don't know what the,
um,
the answer is.
Who were for Ryan racing shoes.
Shoes,
wrestling shoes.
Everybody has smoke with the coffee bean.
They're all over drivers and they all
have Ferrari shoes and I fucking love it.
I love it.
What kind of cigarettes do they smoke?
I'm always,
I don't know what they smell.
It's like a brand that you're like,
where did you buy that brochure?
A tree
bill burr.
Fun Fact.
Morgan Murphy fucking
fantastic boxing fan.
Yeah.
She always has to fight nights over.
I'm like five years deep into
Golovkin and people are now getting,
I'm sorry,
you know,
it's fine.
But I like,
I,
that's what I feel like now.
I feel like I was like
nine years deep into,
into a pack out and like,
then he got bit like it's,
I don't know,
I just find out about things
sooner than other people.
It makes me better.
Well you know about
what you know about old shit too,
you know a little bit like you know,
I dunno like basic shit.
Full House.
You and I had a
conversation about the ram.
Yeah.
We had a long Durang conversation.
I used to fly out.
I would,
I would do overnight from work
and I would fly out to see glove.
I saw Golovkin fight like a Fox
sports for like 2:00 AM fight.
And I was like,
who's this guy?
And I went to every American fight
he had until he was like famous.
Now I can't afford to go anymore,
but I would fly out overnight.
I bumped into La Wanda Sykes on a plane
and we were both like lesbians going to,
uh,
I'm not lesbian,
but I it seem like I am based on
every pay based on everything.
I like saying do I seem
like I'm a lesbian but it's,
it's a for,
everybody thinks that too.
Cause we look good and
blazers and they're like,
oh sorry.
Yeah,
I'm sorry I have a house.
Sing it.
I'll be there in a way because
you're like serious fucking assholes.
It.
You keep saying all these
states are too close to call,
so I call them.
They're spent two 38 50 it's
like a fucking hour isn't it?
It's too late to call
them like Pennsylvania.
I don't understand.
It's too late to call.
You sound like my mom.
It's like,
it's like fun.
No one in the morning,
one of the junkies.
What do you think Hillary and
and Trump are doing right now?
What?
What do you think Hillary and
Trump are doing right now?
Each Other?
No.
[inaudible] 69 that's
the only way triplets.
Somebody suck his dick that way.
They don't look at his head.
I don't think Trump is,
Trump is in like jerking off to celebrate.
He's jerking off to relax cause he's
completely freaked out right now that any
of this is happening.
I don't think he,
I don't know if he wanted it.
I don't know if he's,
that's what you say.
All of a sudden you're living in Brentwood
and you're back walls made out of
glass and you drive a Ferrari and the
guy at the fucking local coffee bean gets
a coke today.
My trainers,
no,
you're a producer.
Producer works on movies
and ain't going nowhere.
So you constantly deal with desperate
people and you're giving them coke and
driving around in a Ferrari.
So your fucking house,
the glass windows.
Just because I think positively.
It doesn't make me sell out.
Yes.
What happens?
I said just because I think
positively it does make me a sell out.
I thought I thought he
liked was fucking around.
Yeah,
right.
You didn't think he was fucking
around in the beginning.
Trump like just throwing his name.
Real conversation.
We have to affect the guy
doesn't really have a plan.
He's having to make this fucking great.
Why are you gonna do that?
Oh,
you'll see.
It doesn't really sound like
a plan after giving an answer.
It's time out.
We just kept riding it.
It's fucking astounding.
It's the most amazing thing
I've ever fucking seen.
We're here.
We're here losing.
Yeah.
T and I still blame him
for ruining my life.
You were good.
You did a good job.
So you know what?
Do we have a precedent?
You did guys.
Guys calm down here after the
who did what announcement.
I got know who's on what
before I keep talking.
I don't even remember.
Brendon was leaving
God damn magician to me.
I'm like,
where's better less went to him.
I went to him to
fucking IPAD,
put it down on a table.
The fucking scream.
They got a black guy or
white guy with white hair.
Jesus Christ.
Diversity in the house.
Good resident.
His hair's gonna change presidents.
Harris Change.
He'll take you.
The emails had to do with this.
How much you think the emails
I have affected this election.
No,
no,
no.
I'm going to jump into this.
It's fun.
It's liberals.
Liberals have ruined this.
They are the ones that fuck this up.
Oh they made,
they made,
they made these sherbet of farmers feel
like they didn't have a voice and then
all of a sudden they rose
back up and they were like,
fuck you with your hand crafted
shoes from Brooklyn and,
and,
and that is what I'm telling you.
I'm saying this from friends
from Florida who voted for Trump.
They just feel like
they don't have a voice.
You get in trouble if you say something
a little racist or a little sexist and
that and that man serious.
If you're a regular person,
you get fired.
And that is what,
fuck this up.
If liberals is just being cool,
like just be like,
all right,
cool.
We'll just won't say the n word.
Like then we'd all
correct.
This is the new McCarthy.
Is it?
Okay Doug,
stand out.
Who are they?
Burn you.
You talk about them.
But we're fed this shit from the media.
Yeah.
Act like the gifts,
not our social circle.
No.
See your friends were upset that they
couldn't be racist or sexist and they felt
like they didn't have a voice to it.
If you voted for a reality TV show star
to be the leader of the free world.
Super Sad.
Don't you guys all wish that Anderson
Cooper was laying his head in John King's
lap on CNN right now?
I wish this is true political
analysis right here.
I wish I knew who the fuck John King was.
I would laugh at that.
I had a bag.
Oh yeah.
Yeah,
that'd be fucking hilarious.
Google,
if you,
if you look at was talking sandy hair,
hair
guy earlier.
We're burst on the fucking,
he's got the shit going on.
He'll show you John King.
No,
this thing is like magic.
It's like that.
The screen is not
connected to the keyboard,
but it all works.
You say anything?
I don't get like kind of fuck like that.
I can do that.
Like how does that work?
Hey guys,
we don't have headphones on,
so if we talk over each other,
do you guys talk over each other?
That's going to be a disaster
for it would been a great point.
Three hours ago.
I'm sorry.
Oh,
okay.
All right.
We give all the money to bill burns.
Come on,
man.
He's got gotta meet.
Bilberry is going
to give it to some awesome
charities and smart guy.
How funny is it?
There's a blonde lady next to the
blackest guy that's ever been on TV in the
last 10 years and then next to
each other talking about the news.
It looks like a health insurance best.
That guy lower cage from Netflix.
I was out there kicking ass.
He's a fucking,
you look at him as the God damn barbarian.
That guy is built like a fucking savage,
Michigan,
New Hampshire,
Pennsylvania,
Wisconsin.
Still too close to call.
I feel like we're having
so much fun in here,
but outside,
close to cough.
Just fucking
eating through people at the mall.
I just came from outside.
I left the 12 just terrified people
at my house to come here tonight.
You're just at your house.
They're at my house.
Interior like people are having tears.
Honestly,
somebody who's crying on my deck
tonight thinking they were going to
God.
You know what I mean?
You didn't win an election.
You're going to start fucking crying.
Go Rake.
You fucking leaves.
Nice people who have Obamacare.
Who's the fucking clouds.
Chrysler gets up.
Seriously.
Liberals need to toughen.
I,
I mean,
I lean left and we left.
They're
right now.
He just wants with the tambourine,
this is like,
I know,
but it's not,
it's not the voice like it
matters a little bit more.
If you lose that takes up
and you're going to be fine.
No.
Yes,
you're right.
You're going to be fine.
Yeah,
thank done.
No,
it's such a disease to think that my,
the person had on a blue shirt,
now my life's going to be better then,
I don't know.
Red fucking bow or whatever.
Whatever the fuck the
checks put in their hair,
they're going to fucking win.
Yeah.
Just,
you're going to be fine.
You make your own opportunity.
You pull yourself up by
your own fucking bootstraps.
The end of the day,
you don't worry American Belton.
Right.
But we're all given.
Some people had given like a one,
three,
another dude gets to aces.
Right?
We get lucky.
We all do.
The guy with two aces doesn't give
a shit and he's never gone to.
And when you're an adult and you realize
that and you play the one in the three
and do what the fuck this,
that's you.
That's your best bet.
To try to get someone with two
fucking asis to give a fuck.
Is this the desk basically a trust fund
kid to get them to give a shit about
anybody below someone
who just owns a Chili's,
forget about the people who work there.
It's fucking impossible.
Most likely,
most likely,
depending upon how they're
raised by their parents.
If they get really lucky and
they find a conscientious parent,
it tries to explain to them things,
they'll get a more nuanced
perspective of life,
but they're never to have the same
perspective as a guy like Mike Tyson.
He grows up in a horrible neighborhood
and learns how to just be the best of the
best with a fury that you cannot stop
and that is only awarded to people that
are suppressed.
There's this weird thing that happens
with human beings when we're suppressed.
When added that emerges is very bizarre.
Intense,
like almost Super Nova type energy that
you see from people like Eddie Murphy or
Richard Pryor or Chris Rock.
There's a lot of them.
Right?
I'll Trump Greg Fitzsimmons
sorry,
bring away to the Joe.
You guys just weren't there.
Sorry.
Can I say that?
Uh,
have you heard that study about like,
you know how they tried to
figure out like if everybody eat,
they always say like anybody can
be president of the United States,
right?
Like anybody,
everybody in America has
the same opportunities.
But what they've found is that some people
have one opportunity and other people
have many opportunities
and that's the difference.
So are you saying the world is unfair?
No,
but you're saying you're saying
100% agree with you.
The world is
fair,
but what you're expecting is people have
the advantage to take the time to have
the,
the maturity to give a shit.
They're not going to do it.
That's not what I'm expecting.
That we have not been connected
since the second you said 50% of it.
I'll take 49
great example.
The Oscars.
Watch the Oscars right?
They're always talking about
more and more diversity,
but it never changes because you're
asking for somebody to give up their
nomination or their seat in the fucking
show and they're never going to fucking
do it because they're cool change for
everybody else as long as they get there
and that's why I won't fucking,
it's very hard to get anybody changed.
Could you ask him the sacrifice
because they're selfish.
It's good.
It's good to teach.
Somebody has on a yellow dress on CNN.
Beautiful.
Don't you guys think that famine thinking
because there's a limited,
there's a limited ability to communicate
with people you didn't know just
recently.
Hey,
what is some 20 years ago?
What is some gum like?
The flavor lasts for fucking
ever and then other gum,
it's like it's gone in a minute.
It's like,
it's like the boy band a gum like,
oh my God,
this is fucking amazing.
And then is,
how do you feel about that
gum gum gum squirt comes,
it's not that it's sports,
the freaks me out.
It's just not,
it doesn't taste good.
Powerful.
It's like mouthwash and the gum.
Tell us about your experience
work because at the
beginning it's just so good,
you know,
and then it just kind of
wears off and you're like,
well,
I just need to buy
more gum.
Are you all right?
You're getting New Hampshire
[inaudible] still too close to call.
You make tanker holaps though.
You're killing right now.
I stance as a crowd and as
we got a score in the back
2021 yeah.
I don't know what that means,
but I'll take it for some reason.
That was a Bruins Tampa Bay score to me.
I thought you said stamp zoos have some
crazy fucking score going on in the
back.
That's okay too.
Iphone guy.
What do you got?
I still got to 38 to 15 what do you got?
Hello?
Trump.
Oh,
come on.
Whoa.
Then one of the fucking pillar,
the red pillar in the corner.
Loving it.
He's going to make his life,
Craig.
Oh,
bullshit aside.
I'll fill all Donald Trump's
going to call you tomorrow.
How weird does this feel?
Hey,
you got to admit this
motherfucker in the corner.
Nobody thought it was
going to be this close.
This is insane.
Who says it's awesome for real dude,
my friend?
No,
judge,
this is what you have to think.
Bill Burns is the guy right
there is said is this,
I'm not going to,
I'm at camp.
I can't say to these people,
Shit that might happen.
Hold on.
I want to hear this dude talk.
What?
It's like a town hall.
Yeah,
family.
Just like a ton town hall,
but nobody knows the issues.
So it's a town hall.
Call it today.
You want to go to the booth.
If you stick your card in each tank,
going over all the different things
that you agree with or don't agree with,
you go,
ah,
I should have fucking
probably studied this.
Hey Dude,
look at all this shit.
I was like,
um,
schools.
Well,
how much do,
well,
how much do they need
when they ask it for?
I don't know how the
fuck the parameters are.
Okay.
Did you guys already know?
But how'd they get on death row?
The fuck they do.
I don't know.
These dudes,
you know something if you
actually researched it,
it's still just as cause confusing.
I'm sure cause I looked at all,
I had all my shy,
my cheat sheet.
I was in and out in 30 seconds but like
every fucking amendment was just like,
hey this is a man men to make sure the
sun doesn't burn out and then we need the
sun to heat the earth.
You're like,
yeah,
I'm for this.
And then the next thing
would be the argument.
It can be like,
actually this doesn't prevent
the sun from burning out.
It's the exact opposite.
This is pouring water on the sun and by
the end of it you're just like I don't,
I don't know who do I believe.
And then you just look
at who was Ford Nra,
Ed Begley Jr.
It was all over the same day.
I knew like who agrees with this?
Who does this disagree with?
And that's what you went with.
That
was it.
But I hate all my shit lined up.
I was looking at all the answers to the
test and I would just flip the page.
Two Up,
two down,
one up,
Bam,
Bam.
Right?
Just want to go to the airport.
I'm ready to go right
through the security line.
You guys have a lot of people telling
you this federation for the person behind
check.
Were you with a lot of
people with their kids?
Oh,
sorry.
Or You with a lot of people
with their kids voting today.
There was a little girl who liked
over explained like how the vote,
how many people were drinking soda
chips in it were volunteering.
Oh really?
Like this is some weird poisoning we're
watching and it's a delicious poison.
Right?
Did people behind me were dragging a,
the people behind me were drinking like
a homemade smoothies and cups with like
glass straws and I was like,
oh,
this isn't,
we're not going the way my line is.
It's like
I brought my,
wait,
can I ask a question for
those who voted in la?
Yeah.
Were you guys like like 90%
yeses with like five nos?
No,
I had a lot of no's.
I had no nose leave then what
do you mean no for nothing?
I figured and then and then when you
picked your judges and third question is
actual human beings.
You can't just yes and no.
No,
no,
no.
I mean I'm just saying it like for all
the things I voted no with the condoms
and then yes and no the condoms.
But like I was predominantly
know what the tobacco tax,
right?
No,
no,
no.
I bought a dance with them.
I bought it.
Yes.
I'm a,
I'm a heavy,
I'll say I'm a heavy smoker.
I voted yes on the tobacco town.
Was another one about building up the
schools and it was presented by the
builders and like those crooked flux.
Yeah.
Fuck them.
Morgan one.
Yeah.
I said,
I am a,
I'm a,
I'm a heavy smoker.
I voted yes on the tobacco tax.
Whoa.
I did.
No,
I think more money should go to research
the shit that I'm doing to myself as
I'm smoking.
Like that's how I feel.
I do.
I feel like I would like to get older and
find out I have something they already
cured.
Honestly.
Energy,
drinks and cigarettes
of stunted my growth.
I feel great.
I voted for the Armenian.
Oh Hey,
he's got to go to billboard on Virgil.
I like him.
You guys all the no on the condoms thing.
Yeah.
No condoms.
No ICAD.
Debs.
What'd you vote?
I voted yes.
Ooh,
love it.
Well because I think uh,
porn is ruining men and I think that if,
if,
no,
she's and how she's right.
I get it.
Cause I voted,
I voted,
I'm sorry.
I think that the one thing that porn is
doing is like not making men like go out
and try to be like fucking
like pickup chicks.
And I feel like if they stopped watching
porn and tried to be resourceful,
that would be fucking
pornography.
No Man to try their thing.
She wants to get hit on.
I thought it was,
she cared about.
No,
that's not it.
Millennials are having less
sex than their parents.
Like guys don't want to go out and
just start a curious,
just out of curiosity,
how could they possibly know
if millennials are having
less sex than their past?
How do you know they do research?
How
to times you've been on the
fucking mall and somebody goes,
can you stop right now?
I want to take this survey.
Anybody intelligent?
I got shit to do.
Slice.
I can tell you I voted.
I think like just young kids are just
not interested in video games and Netflix
and porn and like why would they want
to go out and fucking meet women?
I voted no.
I'm not saying they need to meet me,
meet me spitting in each other's mouths
with the women in his life
and he wants just release.
I'm fine with that.
His testicles
influencing my decision.
Are you released
and it helps to man.
Sometimes if you watch other people,
fuck,
I understand that,
but I think every patient,
everything in excess including
washing your fucking hands,
you've got no still too close to call
people's 10 times a day you need a hug.
Well,
I just think Elvis sudden it makes the
porn straight like what they're doing
going on.
It was pushes it further underground
and makes it more dangerous so the girls
have to have sex in worse places.
That's all.
Does he ever go get rid of
your freedom of speech?
L Know your thoughts?
I'm trying.
I'm trying to yell,
but no,
I'm,
I'm against it.
I'm sorry Sarah.
I don't mean I'm not afraid.
Let's go dirtier.
Let's go fucking release
it to Joe
and after it's done,
you go.
All right.
Whatever.
Alaska,
it's still too early to call.
No,
I don't give a fuck.
I'm talking about making pizza.
Well,
I'll get him.
Let us meet you.
Absolutely.
Ellen,
do you watch porn stare or
are you going to watch boring?
He doesn't watch porn anymore.
See,
I have a theory.
It's the people that feel the one condoms
in porn or like people that say they
hate Kanya.
You just don't watch porn.
You just don't listen to rap.
If you wasn't a wrap,
then you love con.
Everybody wants to hate on
Kanye and hate on condoms.
They're very close.
No Tony Hitch
to if I've got a theory,
I think a person can only watch so many
people fucking this whole lifetime and I
think Sarah overdosed long time ago.
Yeah,
Sarah's been,
Sarah has been like over protective.
She says like two condoms
on her entire life.
She specialized in black dudes wear
timberlands like jump out of helicopters
in this girls and they're run into the
snow and they tripped and the pants fall
down.
The only magnum I want to see,
the only magnum I want to see
in a porno is a big black guy.
Fucking a dirty white trash
white girl named magnum.
I Dunno.
I mean all I know,
all I know is my experience with
it and that and my experience
shopping them out.
I'm going to be honest,
Tony fucked it up.
You guys can all hate me.
It's just like,
oh,
nobody hates you.
I'm not backing down from my position.
I just think that there's too much porn
out there and it's making guys thing
that women want to do those positions
and every time I'm with a new guy,
the new guy in my,
what are you doing?
The romantic comedies where guys
run through airports and fuck it,
I'm going to take the next several shades
of gray was the biggest selling book
in the history of fucking human beings.
Okay.
It brought back were
we're running down a row.
Yes.
Crazy,
crazy bitches across the globe when
asking random dudes and spit them out,
do you understand what the fuck happened?
One person wrote a crazy book to cracked.
That's so true.
It's like we got to keep that door shut.
The lady that's all that.
I just think that it's more interesting
to not try to push me in certain
positions that I can do anymore.
I think a really good point.
Yeah.
I just think it gives men a negative
imagery and a false of what a woman's body
is like and instead of paying attention
to what I need and what I want porn and
then you can't get off and then they can't
get off because they're just thinking
about Sa.
They can't in your circumstance,
but that's what part is.
I'm just telling you it's all I can
think that's what porn is though.
Porn is a false imagery.
It's just something.
Yeah.
Just like Sam said,
it's a romantic comedy.
It's a,
it's the,
why not do it.
Oh Jesus.
Yeah.
For,
for,
come on guys.
Let's get off of this.
Let's just get off.
I just want to be honest with you people.
This might be the greatest
thing I've ever been a part of
my,
put this thing together.
Come on,
sit down.
Sit down.
What are you trying to do?
Come sit with us.
All right.
I Dunno.
I Dunno what the fuck is going
on in the country right now,
but it's still to answer her fucking,
it's two 38 to 15
to 15 yup.
That's,
it's still that.
What are you doing?
You can't,
no,
no.
He's not calling anybody.
This will be a good time
for like a raffle or
auction off.
Do you guys,
what do we got?
I would like to,
I would like to say as
an open minded mail,
I enjoy the discussion with Sarah and I
find it interesting to see a different
perspective and that's
what this election's about.
Cause guess what?
We're all going to internment camps when
he fucking finds out who we voted for.
Trump's bring him back in turn.
Mccafe motherfuckers.
Yeah,
it's great.
We live in a democracy.
Some people want condoms in
porn and some people want
this.
We're two grown men.
Can we vote for whatever
just happened to be illegal.
That just took the sting
off of whoever wins.
Yes.
No,
this thing,
nobody's Java.
MMM.
Have to leave to go next
door and tell jokes.
Going to have the room.
Okay.
All right.
His mother fuckers going to run on.
We're not done.
I know.
At least get Doug back
the night is young.
Hey Russell Peters making
American great again.
She's Canada and Saudi Arabia
and making sure ran great again.
This is all still making
the Philippines great.
I guess Peter,
sorry.
He told me.
Russell Simmons.
Good to ask.
Ladies and gentlemen to the
ambassador of the world.
Russell Peters.
Joe.
No,
no.
He's coming back.
He's,
he's going to go,
dude.
All right.
I really,
what's going on?
Never.
Michigan,
New Hampshire settlement.
Pennsylvania.
Wisconsin is still too close to call.
I'm so sick of fucking saying
that you had how New Hampshire.
It's like fucking one 10 in the morning.
These guys,
these guys are in these guys,
by the way,
on CNN are in great shape.
I'm like,
what is this teen Wolf Blitzer?
Bill who got Michigan,
who got Michigan.
You shoe her.
Anyone?
We don't know what it is right now.
I don't know who got Michigan.
No,
no.
It's all
rock up Michigan.
Doug,
sit right here.
Lean Sarah.
Good a talk on the same one.
You guys look like a couple
that wore the same outfit.
That's what that looks like.
Hey.
Hey Russell in Canada.
How you,
how do you pick your group of
elders that run your country?
Um,
a democratically big go.
We don't have fucking teams over there.
There's no like,
oh,
wear this.
You're that.
It's just like,
hey,
that seems like the right guy.
Why do you guys always try to act
like Canada is like devoid of racism?
Oh No,
it's really then just with the whole,
we just go to pick the guy
who's writing what we do.
I know we all have paper.
Sorry
Christ.
You guys are fucking
the same animals we are.
It's like cubs fans.
The way they try to make them seem like,
oh yeah,
you know,
let's play two and who knows
if we're going to fucking win.
And then Steve Bartman goes to
catch that fucking ball height.
Is that his name?
Bartman,
whatever.
They fucking ruined his life.
They're the same animals that vote for
the red sox to Phillies in the Yankees.
Go Fuck Yourself.
Let's getting political.
What have a lot of people,
why are there to really
hold for Russell Simmons?
I love it.
Canada.
I have a great time up there.
You know Hitler's cars in Ottawa.
If you ever want to see
his parade car,
the one where he could fucking stand.
It was so weird.
It was like a bulletproof car,
but it also was a convertible cause he
was afraid someone's going to shoot him.
But he also knew if he
came out in a great whip,
like you'd get all that extra
fucking pussy afterwards.
Yeah.
He liked cars and he was in a woman.
Does that doesn't mean you,
you,
your,
your pro.
What he did the way you
guys just pulled back.
I'm just saying that one of the,
one of the biggest monsters
of all time when he was alive,
cars existed and he bought one
and if you want to go look at it,
you're like,
wow.
One of the most evil dudes
ever there was sat right there.
All the original leather seats folded up
and he could fucking wave to people or
whatever the fuck it is.
He deal in Vegas.
There was a casino owned by a guy that
loved Hitler and he had all the cards in
the back and he tried to make uh,
uh,
four 20 and two,
a Hitler birthday party at his function.
His casino and they threatened to
take away is his absolutely license,
but he had all the cars in the back.
There's another hit look car
down in fucking Long Beach,
right outside at John Wayne Airport,
tuning in.
Welcome to the brand new Hitler car
podcast live from the comedy store.
There's some Mercedes that
they have who was chairman,
I'm telling you,
dude,
I'm telling you there's a German,
a Sushi spot and has Hitler
Carpaccio it was terrible.
I'm drunk.
That's why we're here.
What kind of casino
games were at the Hitler?
Because Tina,
there's a Mercedes shoes.
You like to put it on black or Bjork?
I should leave right fucking now,
man.
That was amazing.
Shirts.
Shirts off to you.
Great.
Spliff Hinchcliffe Europe again,
New Hampshire.
Pennsylvania was constant still for
whatever fucking reason too close to call.
What the fuck man in the corner does she
have to win all those to have a chance.
Hey Bill,
you have to go.
It's to
Pennsylvania is a big one.
He doesn't listen to me.
You're
so just lie.
Just already good.
I said Trump won.
They fall down fucker with Google back.
There's fact checking us.
Hey,
this just in south park.
Just one Colorado solidarity.
All right.
Now back to uh,
Hinchcliffe.
Now you're,
you're,
you're uh,
uh,
a gay man at your tone.
You're sitting next to dad dress like
the $6 million man without the muscles.
It's Kinda like that to
show you my tax returns.
6 million.
Come on.
It's a Trump reference.
All right.
Fuck you guys.
Hey.
Hey Tony.
That was as good as mine.
That's not a good insult when you're like,
hey,
that was me earlier.
Come on.
Raffle.
Jesus.
Oh No,
I was going to say Pennsylvania's
48.7 to 47.8 for Trump.
Clinton is winning New
Hampshire 47.5 to 47.4 and up,
up by a content.
Got there.
We'll get to say that
again once he's president.
Do you think this is the happiest?
Scott Mayo has been in like 40 years.
He's definitely in charge,
man charge right now.
Scott bail takes way too much shit.
He's the fucking man.
He fucking handle p
handle being a child star.
We're running in the Charles and Charles.
He fuck some of the hottest ass out here
and he has political views that don't
agree with Hollywood couple of ways.
He's a foot Malveaux Hillary just I know
people that do the fucking New York guy
I like,
and I'm not saying I agree
with all of his politics,
but come on.
Is that Sydney is,
that's a funny joke.
I wasn't saying that,
but I honestly do think that he's
probably really excited right now and it's
probably the best day of his life.
And Los Cocktails.
Oh,
I think that people's a cocktail.
It's like everyone that used to be thought
we were all just fucking around more
is for Trump.
Like people who used to have a
career and don't anymore for doors.
Both Dwyer have a life.
I don't need more protection around it.
It's like if you used to have
something you don't anymore,
you're for Trump because
you think it's fucking,
I dunno the Jews' fault or something.
No,
no,
no.
Just some of us would like to go
back to 1950 and Zooey was like,
Murphy was
arrested.
Socks on.
Huh?
That's Bono bull right there.
I have a lot of shit.
Murphy's.
I don't,
I'm trying to do we say that as a joke
until give then you don't say it on a
night where you go.
No,
I'm kidding honey.
She's on the phone.
I'm trying,
I'm trying.
I have a lot of
the
long way around it
and by the way,
I'll throw my hat in that pool.
I have a crush on Morgan Murphy also.
Everybody's right.
Morgan Morgan Murphy.
She's incredibly smart,
great writer.
And um,
uh,
I listened.
This is going to be sound
saxes she has an amazing ass.
She's a great writer.
What an amazing ass and I just got
to put that out with all respect.
She's America's comedian and I'm not
just saying that because she's all red in
the middle as well.
Wow.
Come on.
Are We?
That
was a joke.
That was your bleeding asshole Tony.
When Tony like you had aids 14 years ago.
I actually was cool.
Actually did when it was cool and he
was only on is Tony Aids and the old
school way and kindergarten in the bum and
the bum.
Why do you have to come and spread
that kind of filthy or Peter Morgan?
I was talking to my socks.
I like my,
I wear a lot of socks or
basketball where my staff socks.
I got bill their beer tonight.
Who Do I have a Isaiah?
Isaiah.
Oh,
one time my housekeeper teamed up,
put a,
uh,
I have a housekeeper,
but what time she put a,
a,
she put it Damian Lillard with a,
with a Drexler and I
thought she was racist.
You guys have this,
nevermind.
You guys have housekeeper.
Nevermind.
I shouldn't start talking about,
okay,
let's show drive this
thing into the toilet.
I really fucking bud wiring my in my head.
But Dwyer from Pennsylvania
who coincidentally is
deciding the election here.
Well,
let's see what his vote is.
Nice shot,
man.
It's pretty much down to Pennsylvania.
Wow.
Where are we at?
The land of Sand Dusky is
deciding this election.
All right,
beautiful.
Here was my question originally.
I'm sitting with this fat dude and then
the I thought I should go shirtless
school.
He's not of fat,
but he's
but I.
Dot.
I'm too insecure at 143 pounds cause
it can't eat solid food recently,
but I'm still too insecure to
take off my shirt even beside him.
Take it off.
Oh No,
no.
Okay.
Kid Off.
Take
off.
Take it off.
I have tid herpes and it makes
me feel really creeped out.
What's going on.
Bill bill
is a leading handily in Wisconsin
even though it was too close to call.
He's up 49% to 45.8 at Pennsylvania.
Trump moved ahead.
48.7 it's 47.71 man in the corner
down on the night of his life.
I'm pretty sure that's Donald Trump by
the one man in Hollywood here tonight.
Bill New Hampshire,
47.5 Clinton 47.4 dude,
this is like woo too close
to the car bill with Irma.
Coming to then I think a lot of
liberals going to bed early though.
They go to bed early.
Dog Day.
Yeah.
So you have all the ducks in a
row and then they wake up late.
You're caring about other people.
I'm worried how late this is
that like the red go to bed late.
I
interrupted you right now cause I remember
as a young comic sometimes you'd try
to get pussy onstage or like,
hey,
who's go weed?
I want the drugs.
I really need to bucking gum
cause I can smell my own breath.
I could smell own stink.
Oh where I live,
front guy in the front row was gum gum.
It's fruit flavored dude.
What is technical and gum?
That guy's good.
Right?
If you're going to try
to kill him with it,
that'd be great.
Eric is killing it tonight,
but I don't,
we never going to say another word.
Yeah.
Is that what you want?
Did you want orange amid?
Yeah,
it smells like you sucked
off the side of the freeway.
Adderall is a problem.
I got orange gum.
Looks like we've got ourselves
in a sticky situation.
Everyone.
We're never to just leave
to trying to get it.
No.
Burrs.
The only guy that stayed here
every second of this podcast.
Goddamn right.
Yeah.
What are the boats,
the pork
two 44 to 15 for fucking an hour.
44 to 54 an hour.
You're just trying to figure out
a way to get her from the Lexus
piece of shit froze
again till early to call.
Hey,
fuck that.
How about this whole God damn time.
Come on.
You guys been hanging in there,
hanging in there.
Oh,
they're dying.
Gaul.
I purposely told Chad Shank,
listen,
fuck the audience.
We're going to do.
This.
Rogan was legitimately concerned.
Well,
we're going to overtalk.
Everyone's going to go for the
punchline if we do a live thing,
but no.
Yeah,
he basically said exactly what was
going to happen was going to happen.
Oh
wait,
wait.
Did you guys think this
was going to happen?
Do you guys think this was going to be
the result or did you think you'd be like
kind of half celebrated,
half going,
okay,
it'll be fine,
but we can make fun of what's going on.
But now it's a fucking,
yeah,
no,
no.
The what part of the reason Doug wanted
to cancel it because he figured Hilary
was gonna win.
And he was like,
yeah,
fuck it.
No,
that was the excuse I gave Rogan when
I was begging him to make me get,
please don't make me do this.
And then my life got worse.
Oh,
I gotta be honest with you.
I thought if we were starting at seven,
I thought it was going to be over.
I just thought everyone was going to vote
for Hillary because she was more than
made guy.
He was a reality show star.
And then I was like
halfway through I was like,
Oh shit,
this is going to be a good podcast.
It's still going.
And then somewhere halfway
through that I was like,
oh my God,
this guy might be president.
This is fucking terrifying.
You and I know you knew it was hilarious.
Still about 6:59 PM and
ever since then I'm like,
wait a minute,
this is,
this is fucking crazy.
Hey,
it's Sophie the waitress around here.
Cause she come to the stage,
the stage,
well actually let's
stop the podcast or no,
no,
I'm going to tell Sophie
comes to the stage.
This seems very importantly,
oh no,
it's Sophie related.
I think under Trump
you can just guess any woman to
get you a drink and they have,
that's the new rule.
I don't get these guys offended
by the grabbing and the post.
These stuff.
What are they picking up?
Bowling balls with two hands.
Fucking business.
You do jokes and just jabber,
but did you
get it?
It's not,
it's not an,
I don't,
I feel like,
oh hi.
Can you just talk?
I heard though that a lot of the Poles,
like we all thought that it
wasn't those on that other phone.
Phone is Morgan.
What were you gonna say?
No,
I think it's,
it's,
I feel like there was a,
a,
a national besides Judaism and sexism
that exists and I'm very upset about it.
Hang on,
let me put bill burrs,
golf ball on his feet.
Please.
Ready?
I'm ready to fucking talk
to
two felonies she got accused
of that somehow disappeared.
But if I had one of those,
I'd be hanging out with snowed in Russia.
Morgan,
you know,
I have to be honest with you that the
Democrats did pick the wrong person
because they've done so much shit.
They really are.
The Democrats Bushes.
They've done so much fucking shit.
They had a lot of fucking emoney.
Anime say,
Hey,
not you're saying the Republicans
pick the right person,
which is one of the most,
that's not what I'm saying.
You're putting those words in my mouth.
Well then stop doing that.
Hey listen,
you guys get heated.
If at any point it gets a little
too touchy for the people.
I'll go with licking his tit.
Yeah,
and we'll just get her damage.
Laughs.
I can't have an argument
because I'm not that smart.
I'm just sad
you're saying what?
Go ahead.
No,
make a salient point.
If it gets uncomfortable.
It's right here.
I think he's been Borgen.
I think
make a good point and they're
going to watch this again.
Here it comes to qualified
person and you go,
okay,
why didn't she make it go?
There's clearly people in
this country who are raises,
who are misogynistic or homophobic,
who are Zena phobic?
How can you just blow off all of those?
Like like how many felonies
do you have to be accused of
things as well?
I'm not saying he's a good guy.
Well,
I'm just saying that you can't literally
just say the reason why you're not
voting for Clinton is because you're
a misogynist is actually sexist shit.
She's almost people who voted for him.
It is.
It's like you're saying.
Yeah,
it's okay.
No,
I don't believe that all the people voted
for Trump are smart enough to assess
every wrong doing that.
They think Clinton that I did.
I think that they,
I think that's cause you live out here.
Sure.
I live in a bubble because you live out
here and you think everybody who doesn't
live near an ocean is a dope bill bill.
Oh Shit.
Yeah.
Walsh
is drawn away.
By the way.
Would it be to be in the
middle of a breakup and have
bill burr walk in the door
and go,
I'll take it from,
no,
I'm just saying that people out here have
a fucking Tennessee to call 90% of the
state's flyover states and think that
there were a bunch of fucking morons and
then have the nerve to fucking trash Fox
News where you guys are the exact same
fucking people all the way to
the left and it's annoying.
Absolutely is annoying.
It's annoying.
He's got you there.
It's a total fucking understand
the reason behind him.
But you're literally saying that
the reason why she's not winning,
he says,
because people are sexist
and you're ignoring all of
this other shit and they're
racist and there beside you this take
and they're homophobic and they're 100%
that's it.
I think that said,
Lily.
Say you're telling me,
you're telling me the full
Obama ran against Trump.
This would even been a fucking race.
No.
Well,
I write faster than the
Obama was squeaky fucking clean.
Moderator has a question for Bill Berg.
Morgan,
what about all the stuff that Bill Clinton
was accused of that you know all the
Lolita Express,
all the women that came out are
Hillary basically fucking shaming them.
Like why is that not an issue to that?
The person who was like,
everything that's a Trump is accused of,
no one cares cares.
Bill Clinton paid one
question and you know,
official office,
it's the same thing.
I don't want to say why
we compartmentalize it.
W W gymnasts.
I respect you.
I just walked from his actual words.
I'll just give you just one question.
Okay.
This city rapists.
I can't vote for somebody who's
calling like an entire gender pigs.
I'm not going to do it.
Why are you voting for someone?
Why do you need a leader?
All right.
Just one question and I'm asking bill
because I want your opinion bill.
What?
I hate both of the massage and the
racist fucking hate both of them tired.
This is like the first
week of American idol.
Fuck no,
I hate Trump.
There's no doubt that Trump's an asshole,
but I'm wondering really applies what
Bill Clinton just seemed like nothing when
Trump just to get fused of something
that the charges were dropped and then we
found out that the Gloria alternate paid
off these bitches that come forward and
say all this shit and you're like,
fuck man,
this is some weird shit.
But yet there is actual proof that
are not going to Bill Clinton got on a
fucking flight and when fuck teenagers.
You know what?
It's just like,
why do we,
I love you.
I'm not being nasty,
but why do we,
is anybody watching Westworld?
How great a fucking show is sad.
Huh?
Suck in your test.
Atlanta has a great TV out there.
Everybody understand why we're
talking about Dell Clinton?
It's got to cool it off
every once in a while.
We talking about Clinton.
Yeah.
Why
are we talking about?
Because she co's signed,
done all of them.
The plumber crack is the most
Durbin parts of the whole thing.
Listen,
be here.
We shouldn't even be at this place.
Fuck him.
Bernie Sanders should have fucking him
and they the fuck out of
bed and they put her up.
This would even be close.
This will be an all math man.
You fucking fast.
I don't know about that too.
It would've been mostly blue map.
Who would fucking tell him Sam,
who's gonna kill him?
Dude.
Dude,
you're saying this in Los Angeles.
Nobody say this same argument,
but dude,
no,
because
the emails when they come
out at the to destroy them,
it was all about this fucking emails
and all this shit and it's just all this
dirt that came out at guys.
Guys,
you know something.
We have no control over the all of this.
Let's just stop yelling at hold on.
His bill per telling.
Everybody to calm down.
Is that what just happened?
Right?
You,
we do have control over your
time.
Say Yell sometimes.
Love Morgan Murphy have control over it.
I just had vote and it's
for bill as the moderator.
Quiet.
Do you ever watching the screen
for like fucking two hours?
It's still two 44 to 50 Joe.
Want to call it still people
moving around so I know,
hey,
my questions.
I'd love to hear Doug's squash.
Really have a question.
Is your question?
I want to hear your answer.
It started with David,
massage mini and the racism.
What if you just dislike somebody
further race?
Okay,
let's say do stay with me for a minute.
I stutter a lot.
This is an honest question.
If you hate,
there's people that I dislike
looking at a breakfast,
right?
You don't say it out loud,
but you know in your heart
like feed that thing at home,
but whatever it is going on,
right.
You know that there's
someone that you really,
a lot of people that Scotsman,
I'm going to out him,
he's a faddish.
He's disgusted by fat
people and dangly jewelry.
He can't look at someone with
dangly jewelry at breakfast.
What if you know that you fucking,
hey,
nothing portional but you do like at
what point is that whole political
correctness going to come back to?
Well,
you can't hate people you hate,
you can't hate dicks.
You just have to rehab.
To have a reason to hate people.
What's your reason?
I was bill burr.
You're not
modeling.
I wish you dude,
you're build is perfect.
Can I just say that?
It's a perfect for what you,
this is perfect.
I dream of being like this shirt.
Babies aren't shit.
He's fun size.
He's,
he's fun sites.
He's like,
if he's like winter carnival
and you could just hug it.
What I think Doug was saying,
she was a very lucky
boy killing his podcast.
Is it spent?
It's been two 44 to two 15
for like three fucking hours.
It's just like they just trying to come
up with a way to call this close to
call.
This is not a podcast.
Yeah.
Every feed is different.
That's what's so confusing.
It's like MSNBC.
Everybody has different numbers.
All right.
We got a new logo,
a new level of a dude.
Who the fuck is this lunatic right here?
The file can.
They can't tell him right there going,
it looks for Jeffrey Lord.
It looks crazy.
I wonder.
No,
CNN and there where they were like
a predicting what was gonna happen.
They set up New Hampshire gets this and
have to cause this that Trump could win
and there was clearly a panel of people
and they were miked and you just heard
somebody go,
Jeez,
like you don't know who it was,
but somebody reacted harshly.
They're freaking out.
They still haven't called Michigan.
It's exactly,
I think at this one I feel like we
ought to start taking questions from the
crowd.
We've been babbling for fucking
four hours here from the crowd.
I'll take a question question.
The guy who's killing it,
killing it.
What's the Condo?
Oregon has a great ass.
What's a condom?
That's a great question.
That is a boner killer.
It's a prophylactic depth.
Protects down to the end
of your chef for diseases,
but your balls are left hanging
out to dry like the bay of pigs.
Your boss were out there like
your balls are out there like security.
You fucking serious.
I would make my automate.
Can we just like put on the ballot?
Any rules for porn that we want to make?
Like you can't call someone daddy if
they're only like 10 years older than you,
like that kind of shit.
I respect that you can't have mills porn
that's under 35 is what I think that
should be one of them.
Anybody over the age should or porn that
silver 35 anybody who is in your uncle
that wants you to call them by the name?
I'll call that guy in prison the
way I've totally seen just them.
That should be illegal.
A short game.
Yeah.
You guys got to go,
you guys.
I brought one other question.
Sorry guys.
So we're doing the best we can here.
I know I was going to
take this fucking long.
It's almost 10 30 here.
Any other questions?
I've got a question.
Xanax was down front.
Down Front.
You sir,
next to the one with the purple hair?
No.
How about that guy right there?
He looks like he's working
with some kind of like
the man raised his hand.
Tripoli.
Yeah.
You're recording
the crowds drunker than us?
Yes.
Do you have a question?
A nice question.
I just wanted to know.
Hey Joe,
take one with the women's Mikes.
Okay.
What's your question?
You're sure now?
All right.
Uh,
Morgan,
can I drink with you later?
Can we,
we have a drink with you
political free
on the apocalypse night.
That's,
this is exciting.
Hey,
let's stop doing crowd work.
Let's go back to us.
Sorry guys.
He fucked it up for all of
you all have a drink with you?
Nope.
Nope,
nope,
nope.
Nope.
I don't trust anybody after
this fucking fuck nuts.
Okay.
You get an opportunity to represent the
people and you come in and check off on
your ballot almost.
I don't give a fuck about is great babe.
Girlfriend fucking go back to us.
She's got a choker
and choke him.
I just got here.
Who has a question?
Are we cool with president Trump?
What do we do?
So you should be deported if Trump wins.
Joe.
Yes.
Are they saying they called it?
Oh No,
no.
Still two 46 to 15 bill says too close
to crying yet is the one that's the one
that's the clip.
The red wire or the black wire.
This is the moment and a Tom cruise movie.
We all salute to the scientologist,
you know,
by the way,
how the fuck do you commit to a religion
that was created by an old red head
with crooked teeth in a broken down bone?
You know,
your teeth are fine.
Um,
parents used to live in Pennsylvania,
but the idea of Pennsylvania decided
in the fucking fate of the country
highlights how crazy this fucking
thing in Florida with Amish people,
sixers the super Steelers Phillies,
penguins burgs awesome.
But they're surrounded by a bunch of
people that are just fucking hanging out.
I love Pittsburgh,
Pennsylvania.
Fucking college right in
the middle of the state.
Earl Skagel,
I love you.
Only send us,
you were alive to vote,
right?
He's alive.
He's not alive.
The coach,
he said,
you call it prison.
He calls it heaven.
Can I get more whiskey here?
We're going to Joe Paterno.
Yeah.
That's why we don't want
you guys to be president.
Learn the pens,
paid named coach,
and then we'll fucking elect you.
Hey listen,
I knew what they were getting.
Just send me a text that says the New
York Times says Trump has a 91% chance of
winning.
Whoa.
However,
Trump owns the New York Times.
Hey,
Rogen,
have you heard of that?
Trump talks about getting
rid of the Federal Reserve.
What do you think about that?
It's a good move.
Plus Stop the chem trails
would,
if he tries to do that,
they're going to bring out that fucking
63 convertible fucking the Lincoln
continental down through Dallas.
Drive him around town.
Yeah.
Hey,
here's a bookstore.
Yeah,
nice slow fucking left heart.
Have you ever taken that drive?
You haven't gone through that area.
I've gone to it,
which is what amazes me about Dallas
where if you guys had never been to Dallas
with John F.
Kennedy got assassinated.
They didn't mess with any of that.
It looks exactly like it did when it
happened and out here how they just don't
give a fuck.
Like Rob Robert Kennedy got killed
right down there and we'll show at the
ambassador hotel.
They just plowed that shit over,
turned it into a fucking school.
There's a little plaque on the ground.
Yay.
Died somewhere over here.
There's a little swing set.
They just don't give a shit out here.
That's a rose family.
Well,
Huh?
Yeah.
Earl's Tom Cole.
My Ann was Ethel Kennedy.
I don't like this topic right now.
Trump is to 64 nice headshots though.
Trump has two 64 before to two
15 trucks got Pennsylvania.
Oh,
right.
It's over.
Wow.
This is so
the winter.
Every night,
everybody,
folks,
he go,
he's going to make your life great again,
sir.
He's going to make it great again.
Fuck you.
Hold all calls till that man calls
you and makes your life great again.
Some fucking Philly.
Oh,
sorry.
Wrong.
This is good.
Like a crazy girlfriend.
It gives great blow jobs,
but eventually she leaves you.
This is good.
You feel terrible,
but there's a growth period
that comes after that,
but you reassess your whole existence and
try to figure out why the fuck are you
here?
Why is the man with a cotton candy
here have his hand on the red phone?
What is happening?
What have we done?
What mistakes?
If we may,
let's we examine our existence.
This,
this is what this opportunity provides us.
Lazy Gentleman.
He provides us a moment of harkening.
I'm often of listening and thinking
and centering hadn't money doesn't mean
anything anymore because a
man with the orange skin,
sorry,
I'm fucking nuclear war.
Fuck yeah.
We all like to pile on the walking dead.
That's what I got to get into.
Why you get mad?
She still
sorry about that.
That's B two B,
some motivational video
on youtube very soon.
Yeah.
Man That was walking dead.
People are pussies.
I'm tired of that show.
Kill those fucking pumped gas
zombies and get it over with what?
He's going to fucking win.
This is unbelievable.
Super Bowl three.
This is like the USP,
the Russians.
This is like your brassica beaten you
fucking Miami when they came up with the
camouflage.
This is fucking,
it's like the Patriots beat the rams.
The greatest show on turf
questionably.
Yours is good.
Is this good?
Um,
I don't think so.
If he didn't so relate.
Honestly,
to be honest with you,
he didn't sell,
relate to so many like
overtly racist people,
to be honest with you.
And like that level of ugliness.
If he didn't relate to Alaska,
he got Alaska.
Uh,
they give him three to 47 to
58 he needs to 70 with the APP.
I totally blows me away.
She's a 55 away.
Oh my God.
You mean to tell me the
deadliest voted for Hilary?
Believable?
Unfathomable.
I don't know if this is the least loss.
Seven.
Nothing.
I mean it's kind of funny.
He's 48% of her,
46% of the Michigan.
It's over bitches.
Robbie,
concen happy last year everybody by 3.1
bam,
Bam,
fine.
Alright.
Don't pull your money
out of the stock market.
Everything's going to be fine.
It's the guy with an
orange wig with the tie.
Everything is fine.
All right.
Doug stayed home.
Has a special announcement.
Well,
I figured out how to have the phone put
the Bingos head while she's in a coma,
so she's been listening
for the last thing.
Hold on a second.
Hey,
you guys got to,
you got to stop that song.
Whoever's think Megan,
that song played because that'll
get us pulled up a youtube.
Oh,
don't do that anymore,
dude.
Come on.
Bingo has been listening
for 34 minutes in a coma.
There's
a phone against her hand,
but if bill burr is right that Trump
is president and I'm just going to say
Bingo,
go towards the light.
It's so interesting.
It really is.
It's really interesting.
I mean,
what the fuck have we
gotten ourselves into
ma'am?
You with the fake cat ears
whenever you got going on,
ma'am.
Question.
Okay.
Can you take it from me?
We'd hear you better,
Bert.
Kreischer
too.
It's very loud.
I like it.
When you said,
uh,
when people are elected and
maybe this maybe talk to
fucking behave,
how do you feel that that truck
go back to the Mad Max?
All of a sudden I'm Jenny.
I'm answering questions from the crowd.
I don't know.
You know,
we,
we never know.
It's never happened before
and it's like that's,
that's our big romance.
It's like,
like in a pretty woman,
the hooker with a heart of gold,
hope,
hope.
Some rich businessman comes and rescues
or we hope that some person pretends to
be someone other than
what they really are.
Then it gets into office.
Then once they get in there,
they show us.
They really have purely
altruistic intentions and
they want to take care of us,
but we've never found anybody like that.
You know?
They get inside.
They just want to get their dick sucked.
Paula,
where's that happened?
Did you do to take care of
your wait staff thing yet?
No,
we should do birthdays.
We have 15 more minutes,
man.
I think.
What are we selling?
Merch?
Why did we think this wasn't going to,
oh my God.
The Republicans have won the
Senate to 48 to 46 in the Senate.
Holy Shit.
This is crazy.
We're fucking 50 we're almost
never,
who gives a shit why we
thought this was going to be
350 people here that paid money.
I know,
but fuck it.
Hopefully we can burn.
It was going to be closing.
That's fascinating.
Like,
Hey guys,
let's Sarah get her opinions enrolled.
They count
what's Trump becomes president.
We're going to zip that shot.
Oh my God,
Sarah.
Easily a six and a half.
I'll take it.
I'll give her a six.
You don't want him,
you get caught up living out here.
You think of you,
the whole country thinks
the way you think out here,
ladies and gentlemen.
So lopsided.
And then I heard today that a lot of
people like it when people were pulling,
like a lot of people said,
oh,
I'm not voting for Trump.
And then they did because
they were apparently too
embarrassed to say that they
were so liberal lie.
Right.
Well I don't know.
That's what I'm saying.
Like I know to say you go on social media,
it's all a fucking oversharing.
People won't shut the voices.
Most important podcast
of your life asking,
I'm on more opinion who
are in this business,
live in New York or la and
that's what they were around.
And I think that that's
America and it isn't.
They need to go on the road and start
telling jokes and I'll meet other people.
But don't do that.
I'm like,
I'm not direct polls were in
Ohio and Florida and Miss Sarah,
if I held you ever walk by
anybody taken a poll and they go,
Hey,
can I stop you for a second?
It's like,
no,
I got shit to dope.
Go Fuck Yourself.
They talk to,
I get those phone calls.
I get the phone calls.
I don't answer it but do not call
occasionally.
Let's let Burt tart.
If you did a poll in this
room and you're like,
and they're walking on the street,
you're like,
hey,
have you ever said the n word?
Everyone be like,
no,
never,
but that's not fucking true.
There's people out there that uh,
will be voting for Trump because they
feel disenfranchised by the system,
but don't want to share it and get into
an argument with some fucking random
liberal in the by the water cooler.
That was Doug.
I agree with you
listening folks.
This is,
this is is fucked up
for us as it is for you.
How dare you say that word or
legally you can stay
it now as of midnight.
What time is
one?
Is My phone is,
my point is it's the,
there are disenfranchised people.
Why they called it?
What?
Another person,
Trump is the president.
Adrian Peterson
have a black guy call
a collection election.
Trump is the president comes
the president as we know it.
Yay.
They're legit.
Called it.
I don't know.
They did not call it yellow bird.
Naughty crasher.
You have no shirt on.
You motherfucker.
How dare you.
Maybe I shouldn't be arguing politics.
He's six away.
What?
What is undecided?
Or
are they telling you that on Grindr,
but he'll never win any of those states.
Is that Carlito Alaska,
Alaska,
Arizona and Michigan are done.
It's tough.
Well,
I mean in front of 400 people,
truthfully,
but I heard,
I appreciate it.
Shibley had a great line.
We missed it.
Where are you
talking about Bingo right now will,
ah,
since no one's clicking the microphone,
I'll tell you that my showtime special
airs November 11th At 10:00 PM seriously,
folks,
how great is the fucking comedy
touring the God damn election night.
Huh?
Quick get a Po cave.
We're gonna be okay.
I know.
Feels fucking crazy.
Hey guys,
take care of your cocktail waitresses.
Seriously.
There are doing this to hooking up,
so take care of them.
They're about to be deported.
That girl from Tinder here.
Yeah.
There's just like,
does anybody feel bad
if Trump wins are good?
If Hillary wins are good,
if Trump wins are good,
if I don't know,
we need to see what the
fuck is going to do first.
It aids kind of like
the WME buying the UFC.
We don't know what the
fuck is going to happen.
You have no idea how
exactly right you are.
Doesn't matter if you
don't watch the sport.
Yeah,
it's really going to come
from in is like pray you,
you avoid things that might bite you
or have herpes on their Dicker Lips.
You just,
yeah.
Government.
Fuck them.
You don't need,
all right.
What's up buddy?
Make me smoke DMT fucking 12 years
ago and I've never been right since.
You're good dude.
You're fine.
Steve is smuggled little
this a little bit more,
but this is supposed to be a joke.
The end of the world.
Who gives a fuck?
We did this with the Mayan calendar.
Yeah,
yeah,
the world.
We weren't really upset
about the Czech Republic.
Peters,
you mother fucker.
Doug Stanhope going on tilt.
It's okay folks.
I watched a youtube video today where
these two guys got into a fight and they
went to the ground,
little ground and pound,
and it turned out halfway through.
One of the dudes had a fake leg and it
came off and the other dude was losing
and then the fucking dude picked up the
fake leg and he started beating the guy
with it.
Like I can zone ass.
It was fucking a,
yeah,
it was all like,
I was thinking like if
I was that Kid's dad,
I would have been like,
dude,
you lost the fight.
Give him his prosthetic back and just,
you know,
go to the gym.
I disagree.
As an analyst,
I say,
you got to use what's in front of you.
If it's okay,
if that guy's beating your
ass and he's got a fake leg,
kicked that motherfucker
to the side and go,
what's up now hop along.
But he didn't.
He didn't,
he didn't initiate it.
It doesn't matter.
He was in his house.
The dude was calling them.
I'll know what kind of
relationship the guy reminded.
I call the passive aggressive
piece of shit for years.
Well,
I would just say that I saw the video
and I'm just judging from what the fuck I
saw it.
Come on,
man.
You gotta you gotta draw the line of
beating somebody with their own fake.
Unless that guy's a piece of shit.
Eat Shit.
It just lost his leg last week and
he's still a client who started it.
The trauma,
it looked like the other
kid was the aggressor.
I try.
I'm not the one with the bad leg.
Look,
I'm just saying the guy's fucking
leg fell off and he beat him with it.
Click off the election.
Let's pull up that video.
Then the guy that won his three legs
Shucker I'll take that video and I'll see
you and I'll fucking push up.
One duty got fucked to death by horse.
I've never seen drunk opie and Anthony
show come to him and they told you to
take it down.
X percent of my shows.
Rogan made me watch that after
the fake moon landing thing.
Then it was,
hey,
they're dropping the checks.
Is anybody having an
official announcement?
Because God knows this
fucking half of video,
half a keyboard
doesn't it seems like it's over.
Is it over?
I mean they're running it.
They'll burn the funding.
Only iron man here stayed
here the entire time.
Sarah,
real quick though,
looks like points.
No condoms in porn is going to win.
So uh,
whoa.
Hillary Clinton.
It's up in Michigan.
No,
no.
She's down.
Sorry.
48.2 to 46.6 I thought this is so crazy.
So crazy.
He Won.
He fucking won a reality TV show.
Star is now the leader I one of the most
powerful countries in the free world.
One one or the
fuck.
Fuck Dude.
We got robots.
Can you do me one favor?
Bill,
can you see if Joan Hanchin
toady kind of kicked her ass?
Is that really we?
Hey,
what's that?
Yeah,
it looks unlike Trump.
Kind of kicked her ass.
It's pretty fucking weird.
What's that?
It's two 64 to two 15 right now.
Is this bill.
We are an old Trump.
This is weird corner.
I feel like the me down because Trump won.
The crowd went weird on us.
It's not time.
It's really,
they just dropped checks.
Nothing.
Stop.
You realize a trek.
I had a paid to listen.
These fucking,
you're the worst.
She just finally snatch that joint.
I think Donald Trump just nominated
judge Judy as the Supreme Court.
It's Dr. Ross is the sergeant general.
Hey,
at least we'll all remember where we
were when America voted for it's own.
Nine 11
nine 11 three countries.
This is what God wants.
Payment joke about a
woman being president.
Yeah.
Brad,
do your joke about how I
bet 70 operators audience.
Hey,
how many of you guys are going
to hang in till the final?
You're going to hang in there.
All right.
I know your pain,
your checks and shit.
So we appreciate you guys staying for
the four hours of this fucking whatever
this is.
Well,
here's a joke.
You got it.
You guys are here for this.
So as a joke,
so reality started a criminal president.
Why would you,
why would you be doing joke?
Said the tread is not a time for jokes.
Trump.
You're saying you,
you guys are disappointed,
right?
No,
no,
no.
I feel it.
I feel it like reluctantly.
A lot of us in here wanted Hillary to win,
right?
Yeah.
I kind of did.
I voted for Gary Johnson.
I know Hillary's full of shit,
but I kind of wanted her to win
just to fucking balanced all out.
Good points there.
Marijuana.
Greg goes,
I want to get high too.
For those of you listening at home,
this is,
yes,
it is indeed unraveling,
but he is not that in fact,
reflecting the world that we live in.
Are we not unraveling collectively
fucking reality show in this room.
Yeah.
Maybe the next,
maybe the
person.
It comes from a real,
what?
Real housewife shop.
This lady in front of you with a
purple hair is reconsidering her entire
existence.
Like what the fuck?
What?
What got me here?
What are we doing?
Why is this happening?
What is the formula for happiness?
Darnay he came through.
Who roof,
ma'am.
Ma'Am,
you are committed to those words.
What are they?
Hold on,
sir.
Don't be rude
ma'am.
Christ.
Fuck.
Let Chelsea Clinton in this bitch.
Oh my God,
I hate her.
Is there a drug sniffing dog here,
right,
Tony?
Tony Hinchcliffe isn't
salty and very salty like a,
like a long choice abrasive
to the ladies especially.
Yeah,
like a deadly as cash type of dude.
Something that's happening here.
Russell Peters.
Let's just,
let's eat some silence.
Everyone's already tense.
Let's just make it a little bit worse.
All of our expectations,
it's 11 o'clock folks have,
winning is worse than the
worst heckler where we,
I don't know how to deal with this.
This is not how the thing ends.
I didn't know how it goes.
We're going to rotate people in and out.
We get,
honestly,
if Trump doesn't win in my head,
but honestly as a culture,
it's one of the best things
that could've happened to us.
Not because he's a good president,
but we can't.
We have to revamp this
fucking goofy system.
We can't keep doing this.
We can't keep pretending that every
fucking day of our life has to depend on
four year increments of dictators.
That's crazy.
It's crazy.
For years.
People that have relationships with
people that make billions of dollars to
contribute to the campaign funds.
It's nonsense.
Favorite TV car.
I like any show
fucking rebel flag back on.
I got an ATV.
The Rockford files,
James Garner,
that fucking Firebird.
The fact he didn't have the
Trans am he lived on the wind.
He lived in a fucking
trailer down on the beach,
you know,
but his car is still had a ball.
He hit the button down shirt.
He was still fat.
He tucked it in and he
still had it going on.
I still got some ass around my age.
I'll do you one better magnum Pi who
was beautiful and handsome and he drove
Ferrari three rarely guy lane.
He rarely got laid and we did.
It was special like is this get all
about TC and the hell magnum Pi and this
woman going to become soulmate.
We're just going to go next pomo.
I'm going.
Jan.
Michael ventured in his
hay day before even though
Jan Michael Vincent Changer
island on banana split,
the mechanic would Charles Bronson suck.
Charles Bronson's.
Dick like to Harry implied
all there was implied.
I'll leave the cleaning all the time now.
Oh yeah.
Dirty Mary crazy.
Larry.
Maybe that car.
Mr Belvedere.
I want the lotus from
the spy who loved me.
Oh,
it was for submarine.
This is that.
We deal with predeceases.
You stop talking about cars to go fast
in a straight line and can't take a term
without sending into the forest.
He started talking about
Mr October Jackson,
New York Yankees,
folks.
what if we had our own
g,
t o never that one.
Oh,
that judge was the judge.
Black top head.
The guy fired a few rain.
What's his name?
Dennis Wilson.
Right before he drowned there,
that part of Chevy to test it.
Hey guys,
let's talk all this stuff.
Hold on,
bear Chrysler.
We've lost guys,
guys,
guys.
Guys,
I want to know is Trump our president?
Yeah.
Who Says No?
I had a bunch a latte.
Tricking liberals.
Ah,
Brian's saying we're going to
call this election right now.
The winner of the election
is Mister Bill Burr
for carrying the heaviest
lumber of this night.
Joe Rogan propping me up.
My running mate partner in crime.
I'd say Nice Shit.
Nobody tells the vice president.
It's a good position to be in.
I'm happy to support Mr.
Burn 2020 when a rock.
This bitch,
we're barely gonna put in any effort.
We depend entirely on new people.
Kanye 2020
Kanya get hang out with us.
Well cool.
We're all together in this freak show.
Did Joan Hanson when Lord to
his beat for city council.
I think Chris Hanson,
one
real still watching it like Caddyshack.
Awesome.
At a certain point in time we have
to wonder about your judgment.
Why you're still here.
Come on.
Don't chastise him.
They didn't want to watch it.
Oh,
we all shell shocked you guys hugging
for like four or five hours of a podcast.
Thank you so much.
Wow.
Amanda.
What happens?
We'll get through it.
There'll be sandwiches for everybody.
This is better folks.
Get home sales guys.
Thanks for cutting fucked up.
Fucked up.
Hogan,
Russell Peters,
Eleanor Kerrigan.
Sarah Tiana.
Thanks for coming out guys.
Go.
Ladies and gentlemen,
we're all in this shit together.
Thank you very much for coming out of you.
People are fucking awesome.
This is a great crowd and
we appreciate you very,
very much.
Thank you guys.
Yeah.
Okay.